the senate will come to order and the
chaplain dr perry black will lead the
senate in prayer
let us pray
eternal god
create in us a hunger and thirst
for righteousness
may your presence and power
direct our actions
strengthen our senators
to do the work of freedom
rescue them from trouble
and give them triumph
over life's trials
lord remind them
that all things are possible
to those who believe in you
oh god
who rules forever
hear our prayers
incline your ears to us
and grant us your peace
keep us from slipping
as we trust you
to save us
we pray
in your great name
amen
please join with me and
and uh the recovery
under the previous order the leadership
time is reserved
uh morning business is closed
and under the previous order the senate
will proceed to executive session
resume consideration following
nomination which the clerk will report
nomination united states agency for
international development paloma adams
allen of the district of columbia to be
a deputy administrator
can push teens into darker and darker
places facebook's own researchers
called it instagram's quote perfect
storm
exacerbating
downward spirals
facebook as you have put it was how can
so powerfully maximizes profits
and ignores pain
facebook's failure to acknowledge and to
act makes it morally bankrupt
again and again facebook rejected
reforms recommended by its own
researchers
last week ms davis said
quote we're looking at end quote
no specific plans no
commitments only vague
platitudes these documents that you have
revealed
provided this company with a blueprint
for reform provided specific
recommendation
that could have made
facebook and instagram safe for the
company repeatedly ignored those
recommendations from its own
researchers
that would have made
facebook and instagram safer
facebook researchers have suggested
changing their recommendations
to stop promoting accounts known to
encourage
dangerous body
comparison
instead of making meaningful changes
facebook simply pays lip service
and
if they won't act
and if big tech won't act
congress has to intervene
privacy protection is long overdue
senator markey and i have introduced the
kids act which would ban addictive
tactics that facebook uses to exploit
children parents deserve better tools
to protect their children
i'm also a firm supporter of reforming
section 230.
we should consider narrowing this
sweeping immunity when platforms
algorithms
amplify illegal conduct you've commented
on this in your testimony
and perhaps you'll expand on it
we have also heard compelling
recommendations about requiring
disclosures of research
and independent reviews of these
platforms algorithms and i plan to
pursue these ideas
the securities and exchange commission
should investigate
your
contentions and claims
ms haugen
and so should the federal trade
commission
facebook appears to have misled the
public and investors and if that's
correct it ought to face real penalties
as a result of that misleading and
deceptive
misrepresentation
i want to thank all my colleagues who
are here today because
what we have is a bipartisan
congressional roadmap for reform that
will safeguard and protect children from
big tech
that will be a focus of our subcommittee
moving forward and it will continue
continue to be bipartisan
and finally i'll just end on this note
in the past weeks and days parents have
contacted me
with their stories heartbreaking
and spine chilling stories
about children pushed into eating
disorders
bullying online
self-injury of the most
disturbing kind
and sometimes even taking their lives
because of social media
parents are holding facebook accountable
because of your bravery
is happening
and we need to hold accountable facebook
and all big tech as well again my thanks
to you
i am going to enter into the record a
letter from 52 state attorneys general
and from two members
of the youth advisory board of sandy
hook
promise as long as there's no objection
and i will now turn to the ranking
member senator blackburn
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
entering that letter in the record that
we have from our state's attorneys
general good morning to everyone it is
nice to see people in this hearing
room and uh to be here for the hearing
today miss haugen we thank you
for your appearance before us today and
for giving the opportunity not only for
congress but for uh for the american
people
to hear from you in this setting and we
appreciate that mr chairman i think also
thanks to you and your staff uh that
have worked with our team to make
certain that we had this hearing in this
opportunity
today so that we can get more insights
into what facebook is actually doing
as they invade the privacy not only of
adults but of children and look at the
ways that they are in violation of the
children's online privacy protection act
which is federal law
and
looking at how they are evading that law
and working around it and as the
chairman said
a privacy and online privacy passing a
federal
privacy standard has been long in the
works i filed my first
privacy bill when i was in the house
back in 2012
and i think that it will be this
congress and this subcommittee that is
going to lead the way to online privacy
data security section 230 reforms
and of course senator klobuchar always
wants to talk about antitrust and i have
to give a nod senator markey is down
there
when we were in the house we were
probably two of the only ones who were
talking about the need to have a federal
privacy
standard now as the chairman mentioned
last week
we heard from miss davis who had global
safety for facebook and it was
surprising to us that what she tried to
do was to minimize
the information that was in these
documents to minimize the research and
to minimize the knowledge that facebook
had at one point i even reminded her the
research was not third-party research
the research was there facebook's
internal
research
so they knew
what they were doing they knew where the
violations were
and they
know
they
are
guilty
they know this
their research tells them this
last week in advance of our hearing
facebook released two studies and said
that the wall street journal was all
wrong they had just gotten it wrong
as if the wall street journal did not
know how to read
these documents and how to work through
this research
having seen the data that you've
presented and the other studies that
facebook did not
publicly share
i feel pretty confident that it's
facebook who has done the
misrepresenting to this committee here
are some of the numbers that facebook
chose not to share and mr chairman i
think it's important that we look at
these as we talk about the setting
for this hearing what we learned last
week what you and i have been learning
over the past three years about big tech
and facebook
and here you go 66 of teen girls on
instagram and 40 of teen boys
experience negative social comparisons
this is
facebook's research 52 percent of teen
girls who experienced negative social
comparison on instagram said it was
caused by images related to beauty
social comparison is worse on instagram
because it is perceived as real life but
based on celebrity standards social
comparison mimics the grief cycle and
includes a downward emotional spiral
encompassing a range of emotions from
jealousy to self-proclaimed body
dysmorphia
facebook addiction which facebook calls
conveniently
problematic use
is most severe in teens peaking at age
14.
here's what else we know
facebook is not interested in making
significant changes to improve kids
safety on their platforms at least
not when that would result in losing
eyeballs on post
or
decreasing their ad revenues in fact
facebook is running scared
as they know that in their own words
young adults are less active and less
engaged on facebook and that they are
running out of teens to add to instagram
so teens are looking at other platforms
like tick-tock and facebook is only
making those changes that add to its
users numbers and ultimately its profits
follow the money
so what are these changes
allowing users to create multiple
accounts that facebook does not delete
and encouraging teens to create second
accounts they can hide from their
parents they are also studying younger
and younger children as young as eight
so that they can market to them
and while miss davis says that kids
below 13 are not allowed on facebook or
instagram we know that they are
because she told us
that they recently had deleted 600 000
accounts from children under age 13. so
how do you get that many underage
accounts
if you aren't turning a blind eye to
them in the first place
and then in order to try to clean it up
you go to delete it and then you say oh
by the way we just in the last month
deleted
600
000
underage accounts
and speaking of turning a blind eye
facebook turns a blind eye to user
privacy
news broke yesterday the the private
data of over 1.5 billion that's right
1.5 billion facebook users is being
sold on a hacking
forum
that's its biggest data breach to date
examples like this underscore my strong
concerns about facebook collecting the
data of kids and teens and what they are
doing with it facebook also turns a
blind eye toward blatant human
exploitation
taking place on its platform trafficking
forced labor cartels the worst possible
things one can imagine
big tech companies have gotten away with
abusing consumers for too long it is
clear that facebook prioritizes profit
over the well-being of children and all
users so as a mother and a grandmother
this is an issue that is of particular
concern to me
so we thank you for being here today
miss haugen and
we look forward to getting to the truth
about what facebook is doing with users
data
and how they are abusing their
privacy and how they show a lack of
respect for the individuals that are on
their network we look forward to the
testimony thank you mr chairman thanks
senator black
thank you senator blackman i don't know
whether the ranking member
would like to make it if you don't mind
thank you
chairman blumenthal and and i will just
take a moment or two
uh and and i do appreciate
being able to to speak
as ranking member of the full committee
this this ms halligan this is a this is
a subcommittee hearing you see some
vacant seats
there's pretty good attendance for a
subcommittee
there are also a lot of things going on
so people will be coming and going but
i'm i'm willing to predict
that this will have almost 100 percent
attendance
by members of the subcommittee because
of the importance of this subject matter
so thanks for coming forward to share
concerns about facebook's
business practices
particularly with respect to children
and teens and of course
that is the the main topic of our is the
title of our hearing today protecting
kids online
the recent relevant of revelations about
facebook's mental health effects on
children and its plan to target younger
audiences are indeed disturbing
um and i think you're going to see a lot
of bipartisan concern
about this today and and in future
hearings
they just they show how urgent it is for
congress
to act against powerful tech companies
on behalf of children
and the broader public
and i say powerful tech companies they
are
uh possession possessive of immense
immense power
their product
is addictive
and people on both sides of this diocese
are concerned about this
i talked to an opinion maker
just down the hall
a few moments before this hearing this
person said
the um
tech gods
have been demystified now and i think
this hearing today mr chair
is a part of the process
of demystifying big tech
the children of america are hooked on
their product
it is often destructive
and harmful and there is a cynical
knowledge on behalf of the leadership of
these big tech companies that that is
true
ms hogan i i hope you will have a chance
to talk about your work experience at
facebook
and perhaps compare it to other social
media companies i also look forward to
hearing your thoughts on how this
committee and how this congress can
ensure greater accountability
and transparency especially with regard
to children so thank you mr chairman and
thank you ms hogan for being here today
thanks senator wicker our witness this
morning is francis haugen
she was the lead product manager on
facebook's civic misinformation team she
holds a degree
in electrical and computer engineering
from olin college and an mba from
harvard
she made the courageous decision as all
of us here and many others around the
world know to leave
and revealed the terrible truths about
the company
she learned during her tenure there
and
i think we
are all in agreement here in expressing
our gratitude and our admiration for
your bravery and coming forward thank
you miss haugen
please proceed
good afternoon chairman blumenthal
ranking member blackburn and members of
the subcommittee
thank you for the opportunity to appear
before you
my name is frances haugen
i used to work at facebook
i joined facebook because i think
facebook has the potential to bring out
the best in us
but i'm here today because i believe
facebook's products harm children stoke
division and weaken our democracy
the company's leadership knows how to
make facebook and instagram safer but
won't make the necessary changes because
they have put their astronomical profits
before people
congressional action is needed
they won't solve this crisis without
your help
yesterday we saw facebook get taken off
the internet
i don't know why i went down but i know
that for more than five hours facebook
wasn't used to deepen divides
destabilize democracies and make young
girls and women feel bad about their
bodies
it also means that millions of small
businesses weren't able to reach
potential customers
and countless photos of new babies
weren't joyously celebrated by family
and friends around the world
i believe
in the potential of facebook
we can have social media we enjoy
that connects us
without tearing our democr a part of
democracy putting our children in danger
and sowing ethnic violence around the
world
we can do better
i have worked as a product manager at
large tech companies since 2006
including google pinterest yelp and
facebook
my job has largely focused on
algorithmic products like google plus
search and recommendation systems like
the one that powers the facebook news
feed
having worked on four different types of
social networks
i understand how complex and nuanced
these problems are
however
the choices being made inside of
facebook are disastrous
for our children for our public safety
for our privacy and for our democracy
and that is why we must demand facebook
make changes
during my time at facebook first working
as the lead product manager for civic
misinformation and later on counter
espionage
i saw facebook repeatedly encounter
conflicts between its own profits and
our safety facebook consistently
resolved these conflicts in favor of its
own profits
the result has been more division more
harm
more lies more threats and more combat
in some cases this is this dangerous
online talk has led to actual violence
that harms and even kills people
this is not simply a matter of certain
social media users being angry or
unstable
or about one side being radicalized
against the other it is about facebook
choosing to grow at all costs becoming
an almost trillion dollar company by
buying its profits with our safety
during my time at facebook i came to
realize a devastating truth
almost no one outside of facebook knows
what happens inside of facebook
the company intentionally hides vital
information from the public from the us
government and from governments around
the world
the documents i have provided to
congress prove that facebook has
repeatedly misled the public
about what its own research reveals
about the safety of children
the efficacy of its artificial
intelligence systems and its role in
spreading divisive and extreme messages
i came forward because i believe that
every human being
deserves the dignity of the truth
the severity of this crisis demands that
we break out of our previous regulatory
frames
facebook wants to trick you into
thinking
that privacy protections or changes to
section 230 alone will be sufficient
while important these will not get to
the core of the issue which is that no
one truly understands the destructive
choices made by facebook
except facebook
we can afford nothing less than full
transparency
as long as facebook is operating in the
shadows hiding its research from public
scrutiny it is unaccountable
until the incentives change
facebook will not change
left alone facebook will continue to
make choices that go against the common
good
our common good
when we realized big tobacco was hiding
the harms it caused the government took
action
when we figured out cars were safer with
seat belts the government took action
and when our government learned that
opioids were taking lives the government
took action
i implore you to do the same here
today facebook shapes our perception of
the world by choosing the information we
see
even those who don't use facebook are
impacted by the majority who do
a company with such frightening
influence over so many people
over their deepest thoughts feelings and
behavior needs real oversight
but facebook's closed design
means it has no real oversight
only facebook knows how it personalizes
your feed for you
at other large tech companies like
google
any independent researcher can download
from the internet
the company's search results and write
papers about what they find
and they do
but facebook hides behind walls that
keeps researchers and regulators from
understanding the true dynamics of their
system
facebook will tell you privacy means
they can't give you data
this is not true
when tobacco companies claimed that
filtered cigarettes were safer for
consumers
scientists could independently
invalidate these marketing messages
and confirm that in fact they posed a
greater threat to human health
the public cannot do the same with
facebook we are given no other option
than to take their marketing messages on
blind faith
not only does the company hide most of
its own data
my disclosure has proved that when
facebook is directly asked questions as
important as how do you impact the
health and safety of our children
they mislead
and they
they choose to mislead and misdirect
facebook has not earned our blind faith
this inability to see into facebook's
actual systems and confirm how they work
is communicate it and work as
and confirm that they work as
communicated is like the department of
transportation regulating cars
by only watching them drive down the
highway
today no regulator has a menu of
solutions for how to fix facebook
because facebook didn't want them to
know enough about what's causing the
problems
otherwise they wouldn't otherwise there
wouldn't have been need for a
whistleblower
how is the public supposed to assess if
facebook is resolving conflicts of
interest in a way that is aligned with
the public good if the public has no
visibility into how facebook operates
this must change
facebook wants you to believe that the
problems we're talking about are
unsolvable
they want you to believe in false
choices
they want you to believe that you must
choose between a facebook full of
divisive and extreme content or losing
one of the most important values our
country was founded upon
free speech
that you must choose between public
oversight of facebook's choices and your
personal privacy
that to be able to share fun photos of
your kids with old friends you must also
be inundated with anger driven virality
they want you to believe that this is
just part of the deal
i am here today to tell you that's not
true
these problems
are solvable
a safer
free speech respecting
more enjoyable social media is possible
but there's one thing that i hope
everyone takes away from these
disclosures it is that facebook can
change but is clearly not going to do so
on its own
my fear is that without action divisive
and extremist behaviors we see today are
only the beginning what we saw in
myanmar and are now seen in ethiopia are
only the opening chapters of a story so
terrifying no one wants to read the end
of it
congress can change the rules that
facebook plays by and stop the many
harms it is now causing
we now know the truth about facebook's
destructive impact
i really appreciate the seriousness
which the members of congress and the
securities and exchange commission are
approaching these issues
i came forward at great personal risk
because i believe we still have time to
act
but we must act now
i'm asking you our elected
representatives to act
thank you
thank you miss haugen thank you for
taking that personal risk and we will do
anything and everything
to protect
and stop any retaliation against you in
any legal action that the company may
bring to bear or anyone else and we've
made that i think very clear
in the course of these proceedings
i want to ask you about this idea of
disclosure you've talked about
uh
looking
in effect at a car going down the road
and we're going to have five-minute
rounds of questions maybe a second round
if you're
willing to do it
we're here today to look under the hood
and that's what we need to do more in
august senator blackburn and i wrote to
mark zuckerberg and we asked him pretty
straightforward questions about how the
company
works and safeguards children and teens
on instagram facebook dogs
duff sidetracked
in effect misled us
so i'm going to ask you a few straight
forward questions to break down some of
what you have said and
if you can answer them yes or no that
would be great
as facebook's research its own research
ever found
that its platforms can have a negative
effect
on children and teens mental health or
well-being
many of facebook's internal research
reports indicate that
facebook has a serious negative harm on
a non-significant not a significant
portion of teenagers and and younger and
children
and has facebook ever offered features
that it knew had a negative effect
on children's and teen's mental health
facebook knows that it's amplification
algorithms things like engagement based
ranking on instagram can lead children
from very innocuous topics like healthy
recipes i think all of us can eat a
little more healthy
all the way from just something innocent
like healthy recipes to anorexia
promoting content over a very short
period of time
and has facebook ever found again in its
research that kids show sign of
addiction
on instagram
facebook has studied a pattern that they
call problematic use what we might more
commonly call addiction
it has a very high bar for what it
believes it is it says you
you self-identify that you don't have
control over your usage and that it is
materially harming your health your
schoolwork or or your your physical
health
five to six percent of 14 year olds have
the self-awareness to admit both those
questions it is likely that far more
than five to six percent of 14 year olds
are lit are even are addicted to
instagram
last thursday uh my colleagues and i
asked ms davis who was representing
facebook
about how the decision would be made
whether to
pause permanently instagram for kids
and she said quote there's no one person
who makes a decision like that
we think about it that
collaboratively
it's as though she couldn't mention mark
zuckerberg's name
isn't he the one who will be making this
decision from your experience in the
company
mark holds a very unique role in on the
tech industry in that he holds
over 55 of all the voting shares for
facebook
there are no similarly powerful
companies that are as unilaterally
controlled um and in the end the buck
stops with mark there is no one
currently holding mark accountable but
himself and mark zuckerberg in effect is
the algorithm designer in chief correct
um
i received an mba from harvard and they
emphasized to us that we are responsible
for the organizations that we build
mark has built an organization that is
very metrics driven that isn't it is
intended to be flat there is no
unilateral responsibility the metrics
make the decision unfortunately that
itself is a decision
and in the end if he is the ceo and the
chairman of facebook he is responsible
for those decisions
the buck stops with him the buck stops
with him
uh
and speaking of the buck stopping
you have said that
facebook should declare moral bankruptcy
i agree yeah i think it's its actions
and its failure to acknowledge its
responsibility
indicate moral bankruptcy there is a
cycle occurring inside the company where
facebook has struggled for a long time
to recruit and retain the number of
employees it needs to tackle the large
scope of projects that it is chosen to
take on
facebook is stuck in a cycle where
it struggles to struggles to hire
that causes it to understaff projects
which causes scandals which then makes
it harder to hire
part of why facebook needs to come out
and say we did something wrong we made
some choices that we regret is the only
way we can move forward and heal
facebook is we first have to admit the
truth
like the way we'll have reconciliation
and we can move forward is by first
being honest and declaring moral
bankruptcy being honest and
acknowledging that facebook has caused
an aggravated a lot of pain simply make
more money
and it has
profited off spreading disinformation
and misinformation
and sowing hate
faint facebook's
uh answers to facebook's destructive
impact always seems to be
more facebook we need more facebook
which means more pain
and more money for facebook
would you agree
i don't think at any point facebook set
out to make a destructive platform i
think it is a challenge of that facebook
has set up an organization
where the parts of the organization
responsible for growing and expanding
the organization
are separate and not
not regularly cross-pollinated with the
parts of the company that focus on the
harms that the company is causing
and as a result regularly integrity
actions projects that were hard fought
by the teams trying to keep us safe are
undone by new growth projects that
counteract those same remedies
so i do think it's a thing of there are
organizational problems
that need oversight and facebook needs
help in order to move forward to a more
healthy place
and whether it's teens bullied into
suicidal thoughts
or the genocide of ethnic minorities in
myanmar
or fanning the flames of division
within our own country or in europe
they are ultimately responsible for the
immorality
of the pain that's caused
facebook needs to take responsibility
for the consequences of its choices
um it needs to be willing to accept
small trade-offs on profit and i think i
think just that act of being able to
admit that it's a mixed bag is important
and i think what we saw from antigone
last week is an example of the kind of
behavior we need to support facebook and
growing out of which is instead of just
focusing on all the good they do
admit they have responsibilities to also
remedy the harm but mark zuckerberg's
new policy is
no apologies
no admissions no acknowledgement
nothing to see here
we're going to deflect it and go sailing
i turn to the ranking member
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony uh i want to stay with mrs
davis in some of her comments because i
had asked her last week about the
underage users
and she had made the comment i'm going
to quote from her testimony if we find
an account of someone who's under 13 we
remove them in the last three months we
removed 600 000 accounts of under 13
euros end quote
and i have to tell you
it seems to me that there's a problem if
you have 600
000
accounts from children who ought not to
be there in the first place so what did
mark zuckerberg know about facebook's
plans to bring kids on
as new users and advertise to them
there are reports within facebook that
show cohort analyses where they they
examine at what ages do people join
facebook and instagram
and based on those cohort analyses
so
facebook likes to say children lie
about their ages to get onto the
platform
the reality is enough kids tell the
truth that you can work backwards to
figure out what are approximately the
real ages of anyone who's on the
platform
when facebook does cohort analyses and
looks back retrospectively
and discovers things like you know up to
10 to 15 percent of even 10 year olds in
a given cohort may be on facebook or
instagram
okay so this is why
adam missouri who's the ceo of instagram
would have replied to jojo siwa when she
said to him oh i've been on instagram
since i was eight he said he didn't want
to know that ah so it would be for this
reason correct um
a pattern of behavior that i saw at
facebook was that often problems were
so understaffed that there was a kind of
an implicit discouragement from having
better detection systems so for example
i worked my last team at facebook was on
the counter espionage team within the
threat intelligence org and at any given
time our team could only handle a third
of the cases that we knew about
we knew that if we built even a basic
detector we would likely have many more
cases okay then similarly
yeah let me ask you this
so you look at the way that they have
the data but they're choosing to keep
that data and advertise from it right
you sell it to third parties so what
does facebook do you've got these 600
000 accounts that ought not to be on
there
anymore
and right
but then you delete those accounts but
what happens to that data does facebook
keep that data do they keep it until
those children go to age 13 since as
you're saying they can work backward and
f figure out the true age of a a user so
what do
they do with it do they delete it do
they store it do they
keep it how do they process that
um
i am
my understanding of facebook's data
retention policies and i want to be
really clear i didn't work directly on
that is that they delete when they
delete an account they delete all the
data then i believe 90k is in compliance
with gdpr um and with regard to children
underage on the platform facebook would
do substantially more to detect more of
those children and they should have to
publish for congress those processes
because there are lots of subtleties and
those things and they can be much more
effective than probably what they're
doing today got it
now staying with this underage children
since this hearing is all about kids and
about online privacy i want you to tell
me
how facebook is able to do market
research
on these children that are under age 13
because mrs davis was really
she didn't deny this
last week
so how are they doing this do they
bring kids into focus groups with their
parents
how do they get that permission she said
they got permission from parents is
there a permission slip
or a form
that gets assigned and then how do they
know which kids
to target
um
there's a bunch to unpack there uh we'll
start with maybe how did they recruit
children for focus groups um or
recruit teenagers most tech companies
have systems where they can
analyze the data that is on their
servers so
most of the focus groups i read
or that i saw analysis of were around
messenger kids
which has children on it
and those focus groups appear to be
children interacting in person
often large tech companies use either
sourcing agencies that will go and
identify people who meet certain
demographic criteria or they will reach
out directly based on uh data on the
platform so for example on the case of
messenger kids maybe you would want to
study a child that was an active user
and one that was a less active user you
might reach out to some that came from
each population and so these are
children that are under age 13 yeah
and they know it
um for for some of these studies and i
assume they get i assume they get
permission but i don't work on that okay
well we're still waiting to get a copy
of that parental consent form and that
would involve children um my time is
expired mr chairman i'll save my other
questions for our second round if we're
able to get those thank you great thank
you senator blackburn senator klobuchar
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you so much ms huggin for shedding a
light on how facebook time and time
again has put profit over people
uh when their own research found that
more than 13 percent of teen girls say
that instagram made their thoughts of
suicide worse what did they do they
proposed instagram for kids which has
now been put on pause because of public
pressure
when they found out that their
algorithms are fostering polarization
misinformation
and hate
that they allowed 99
of their violent contact to remain
unchecked on their platform including
lead up to the january 6 insurrection
what did they do
they now as we know mark zuckerberg is
going sailing and saying no apologies
i think the time has come for action and
i think you are the catalyst for that
action
you have said privacy legislation is not
enough i completely agree with you but i
think you know we have not done anything
to update our privacy laws in this
country our federal privacy laws nothing
zilch in any major way why because there
are lobbyists around every single corner
of this building that have been hired by
the tech industry we have done nothing
when it comes to making the algorithms
more transparent allowing for the
university research that you refer to
why because facebook and the other tech
companies are throwing a bunch of money
around this town and people are
listening to them we have done nothing
significantly past although we are on a
bipartisan basis working in the
antitrust subcommittee to get something
done on consolidation which you
understand allows the dominant platforms
um to control all this like the bullies
in the neighborhood buy out the
companies that maybe could have competed
with them and added the bells and
whistles so the time for action is now
so i'll start i'll start with something
that i asked facebook's head of safety
when she testified before us last week i
asked her how they estimate the lifetime
value of a user for kids who start using
their products before they turn 13. she
evaded the question and said that's not
the way we think about it
is that right or is it your experience
that facebook estimates and that and
puts a value on how much money they get
from users in general i'll get to kids
in a second is that a motivating force
for them
um
based on what i saw in terms of
allocation of integrity spending so one
of the things disclosed in the wall
street journal was that i believe it's
like 87 of all the misinformation
spending is spent on english but only
about like nine percent of the users are
english speakers um it seems that that
facebook invests more and users who make
them more money even though the danger
may not be evenly distributed based on
profitability does it make sense that
having a younger person get hooked on
social media
at a young age makes them more
profitable over the long term as they
have a life ahead of them facebook's
internal documents talk about the
importance of getting younger users for
example tweens onto instagram like
instagram kids because they need to have
um
like they know that children bring their
parents online and things like that and
so they understand the value of younger
users for the long-term success of
facebook facebook reported advertising
revenue to be 51 and 58 cents per user
last quarter in the u.s and canada
when i asked miss davis how much of that
came from instagram users under 18 she
wouldn't say
do you think that teens are profitable
for their company i would assume so
based on advertising for things like
television uh you get much substantially
higher advertising rates for customers
who don't yet have preferences or habits
and so i'm i'm sure they're some of the
more profitable users on facebook but i
do not work directly on that
another major issue that's come out of
this eating disorders
studies have found that eating disorders
actually have the highest mortality rate
of any mental illness
for women and i led a bill on this with
centers capital and baldwin that we
passed into law
and i'm concerned that this algorithms
that they have pushes outrageous content
um
promoting anorexia and the like i know
it's personal to you
uh do you think that their algorithms
push some of this content to young girls
facebook knows that their the
engagement based ranking the way that
they pick the content in instagram for
young users for all users
um amplifies preferences and they have
done something called a proactive a
proactive incident response where they
take things they've heard for example
like
can you be led by the algorithms to
anorexia content and they have literally
recreated that experiment themselves and
confirmed yes this this happens to
people so facebook knows that they are
that they are leading young users to
anorexia content
do you think they are deliberately
designing their product to be addictive
beyond even that content
uh facebook has a long history of having
a successful and very effective growth
division
where they take little tiny tweaks and
they constantly constantly constantly
are trying to optimize it to grow
those kinds of stickiness could be
construed as things that facilitate
addiction right last thing i'll ask is
we've seen the same kind of content in
the political
world you brought up other countries and
what's been happening there on 60
minutes you said that facebook
implemented safeguards to reduce
misinformation ahead of the 2020
election but turned off those safeguards
right after the election
and you know that the insurrection
occurred january 6 do you think that
facebook turned off the safeguards
because they were costing the company
money because it was reducing profits
facebook has been emphasizing a false
choice they've said uh the safeguards
that were in place before the election
implicated free speech the choices that
were happening on the platform were
really about how reactive and twitchy
was the platform right like how viral
was the platform and facebook
changed those safety defaults in the
run-up to the election because they knew
they were dangerous
and because they wanted that growth back
they wanted the acceleration of the
platform back after the election they re
they returned to their original defaults
and the fact that they had to break the
glass on january 6th and turn them back
on
i think that's deeply problematic agree
thank you very much for your bravery and
coming forward
senator thune
thank you mr chair and uh
ranking member blackburn um
i've been arguing for some time that it
is time for congress to act and i think
the question is always what is the
correct way to do it the right way to do
it consistent with
our first amendment right to free speech
this committee uh doesn't have
jurisdiction over the antitrust issue
that's the judiciary committee and i'm
not averse to looking at the
monopolistic
nature of facebook honestly i think
that's a real issue that needs to be
examined and perhaps addressed as well
but at least under this committee's
jurisdiction there are a couple of
things i think we can do and i have a
piece of legislation and senators
blackburn and blumenthal are both
co-sponsors
uh called the filter bubble transparency
act and essentially what it would do is
give users the options
to engage with social media platforms
without being manipulated
by these secret formulas that
essentially dictate the content that you
see when you open up an app or log on to
a website
we also i think need to hold big tech
accountable by reforming section 230
and one of the best opportunities i
think to do that at least for in a
bipartisan way is the platform
accountability and consumer transparency
or the pact act and that's legislation
that i've co-sponsored with senator
schatz
which in addition to stripping section
230 protections for content that a court
determines to be illegal
the pact act would also increase
transparency and due process for users
around the content moderation
process and importantly in the context
we're talking about today with this
hearing with a major big tech
whistleblower the packed act would
explore the viability of a federal
program for big tech employees to blow
the whistle on wrongdoing inside the
companies where they work
in my view we should encourage employees
in the tech sector like you to speak up
about
questionable practices of big tech
companies so we can among other things
ensure that americans are fully aware of
how social media platforms are using
artificial intelligence and opaque
algorithms to keep them hooked on the
platform
so let me uh miss haugen just ask you
we've learned from the information that
you've provided that facebook conducts
what's called engagement based ranking
which you've described is very dangerous
could you talk more about why
engagement-based ranking is dangerous
and do you think congress
should seek to pass legislation like the
filter bubble transparency act that
would give users the ability to avoid
engagement-based ranking altogether
facebook is going to say
you don't want to give up engagement
based ranking you're not going to like
facebook as much if we're not picking
out the content for you
that's that's just not true there are a
lot of facebook likes to present things
as false choices like you have to choose
between having lots of spam like let's
say imagine we ordered our feeds by time
like on imessage or on um
there are other forms of social media
that are chronologically based
they're going to say you're going to get
spam you're spammed like you're not
going to enjoy your feed the reality is
that those experiences have a lot of
permutations there are ways that we can
make those experiences where computers
don't regulate what we see we together
socially regulate what we see
but they don't want us to have that
conversation because facebook knows that
when they pick out their content that we
focus on using computers we spend more
time on their platform they make more
money
the dangers of engagement-based ranking
are that facebook knows
that content that elicits an extreme
reaction from you is more likely to get
a click a comment or re-share
and it's interesting because those
clicks and comments and reshares aren't
even necessarily for your benefit it's
because they know that other people will
produce more content if they get the
likes and comments and ratios they
prioritize content in your feed so you
will give little hits of dopamine to
your friends so they will create more
content and they have run experiments on
people produce their side experiments
where they have confirmed this
so
you you and your um
part of the information you provided the
wall street journal
it's been found that facebook altered
its algorithm in an attempt to boost
these meaningful social interactions or
msi
but rather than strengthening bonds
between family and friends on the
platform the algorithm instead rewarded
more outrage and sensationalism and i
think facebook would say that its
algorithms are used to connect
individuals with other friends and
family that are largely positive
do you believe that facebook's
algorithms make its platform a better
place for most users and should
consumers
have the option
to use facebook and instagram without
being manipulated by algorithms designed
to keep them
engaged on that platform i strongly
believe like i've spent most of my
career working on systems like
engagement based ranking like when i
come to you and say these things i'm
basically damning ten years of my own
work right
um
engagement based ranking facebook says
we can do it safely because we have ai
you know the artificial intelligence
will find the bad content that we know
our engagement based ranking is
promoting they've written blog posts on
how they know engagement based ranking
is dangerous but the ai will save us
facebook's own research says they cannot
adequately identify dangerous content
and as a result those dangerous
algorithms that they admit are picking
up the the the extreme sentiments the
division
they can't protect us from the harms
that they know exist in their own system
and so i i i don't think it's just a
question of saying should people have
the option of choosing to not be
manipulated by their algorithms
i think if we had appropriate oversight
or if we were formed 230 to make
facebook responsible for the
consequences of their intentional
ranking decisions
i think they would they would get rid of
engagement based ranking because it is
causing um teenagers to be exposed to
more anorexia content it is pulling
families apart and in places like
ethiopia it's literally fanning ethnic
violence
i encourage reform of these platforms
not not
picking and choosing individual ideas
instead making the platforms themselves
safer less twitchy less reactive less
viral because that's how we scalably
solve these problems thank you miss
chair i i would uh simply say let's uh
let's get to work so we got some things
we can do here thanks i agree thank you
senator schatz thank you mr chairman
ranking member thank you for your
courage in coming forward
was there a particular moment
when you came to the conclusion
that
reform from the inside was impossible
and that you decided to be a
whistleblower
there was a long series of moments where
i became aware that uh facebook went
faced with conflicts of interest between
its own profits and the common good
public safety that facebook consistently
chose to prioritize its profits
i think the moment which i realized
we needed to get help from the outside
that the only way these problems would
be solved is by solving them together
not solving them alone was when civic
integrity was dissolved following the
2020 election it really felt like a
betrayal of the promises that facebook
had made to people who had sacrificed a
great deal to keep the election safe
by basically dissolving our community
and integrating in just other parts of
the company and when i know their their
response is that they've sort of
distributed the duties
yeah that's an excuse right
um
i i cannot see into the hearts of other
men and i i i don't know what to do let
me say it this way it won't work right i
i i can tell you that when i left the
company so my the people who i worked
with were disproportionately maybe
75 of my pod of seven people um so those
are product managers program managers
most of them had come from civic
integrity
all of us left
the inauthentic behavior pod uh either
for other parts of the company or the
company entirely over the same six week
period of time so six months after the
reorganization we had clearly lost faith
that those changes were coming
you said in your opening statement that
they know how to make facebook and
instagram
safer so
thought experiment you are now
the chief executive officer and chairman
of the company
what changes would you immediately
institute
um i
would immediately
establish a policy of how to share
information and research from inside the
company with appropriate oversight
bodies like congress
i would
i would give proposed legislation to
congress saying here's what an effective
oversight agency would look like i would
actively engage with academics to make
sure that that
people who are
who are confirming our facebook's
marketing messages true have the
information they need to confirm these
things
and i would
immediately implement the quote soft
interventions that were identified to
protect the 2020 election so that's
things like requiring someone to click
on a link before re-sharing it because
other companies like twitter have found
that that significantly reduces
misinformation no one is censored by
being forced to click on a link before
re-sharing it
thank you i want to pivot back to uh
instagram's uh targeting of kids we all
know that they announced a pause
but that reminds me of what they
announced
when they were going to
issue a digital currency and they got
beat up by the u.s senate banking
committee and they said never mind
and now they're coming back around
hoping that nobody notices that they
are going to try to issue a currency now
let's set aside for the moment
the sort of
the the business model which appears to
be gobble up everything do everything
that's the gross growth strategy
do you believe that they're actually
going to discontinue instagram kids or
they're just waiting for the dust to
settle
um
i would be sincerely surprised if they
do not continue working on instagram
kids and i would be amazed if a year
from now we don't have this conversation
again
why
facebook understands that if they want
to continue to grow they have to find
new users they have to make sure that
that the next generation is just as
engaged with instagram as the current
one
um and the way they'll do that is by
making sure that children
establish habits before they have good
self-regulation by hooking kids by
hooking kids
i would like to emphasize one of the
documents that we sent in on problematic
use examined the rates of problematic
use by age and that peaked with 14 year
olds it's just like cigarettes teenagers
don't have good self-regulation they say
explicitly
i feel bad when i use instagram and yet
i can't stop
um we need to protect the kids
just my final question i have a long
list of
misstatements
and outright lies from the company i
don't have the time to read them but
you're
as intimate with all these
deceptions as i am so i will just jump
to the end
if you were
a member of this panel would you believe
what facebook is saying
i would not believe
uh facebook has not earned our right to
just have blind trust in them
trust is last week one of the most
beautiful things that i heard on the on
the committee was um
trust is earned and facebook has not
earned our trust
thank you
thanks senator schatz senator
moran uh and then uh we've been joined
by the chair
senator cantwell she'll be next we're
gonna break at about 11 30 if that's
okay because we have a vote
um and then we'll reconvene okay
mr chairman thank you uh the
conversation so far reminds me that you
and i ought to resolve our differences
and uh introduce legislation so as
senator thune said let's go to work
our differences are very minor
or they seem very minor in the face of
the
revelations that we've now seen so i'm
hoping we can move forward senator
miranda i i share that view mr chairman
thank you
uh thank you very much uh for your
testimony
what examples do you know we've talked
about particularly children teenage
girls in uh specifically but what other
examples do you know about where
facebook or instagram
knew its decisions would be harmful
to its users but still proceeded with
the with the
plan
and executed those harmful
that harmful behavior
facebook's internal research is aware
that there are a variety of problems
facing children on instagram that are um
they know that severe harm is happening
to children for example in the case of
bullying
facebook knows that instagram
dramatically changes the experience of
high school so when we were in high
school when i was in high school uh most
kids you looked at me and changed your
your word
sorry
the when i was in high school you know
or most kids have positive home lives
like it doesn't matter how bad it is at
school
kids can go home and reset for 16 hours
kids kids who are bullied on instagram
the bullying follows them home it
follows them into their bedrooms the
last thing they see before they go to
bed at night is someone being cruel to
them or the first thing they see in the
morning is someone being cruel to them
kids are learning that their own friends
like people who they care about them are
cruel to them
like think about how that's going to
impact their domestic relationships when
they become 20-somethings or
30-somethings to believe that people who
care about you are mean to you
um facebook knows that parents today
because they didn't experience these
things they never experienced this
addictive experience with a piece of
technology they give their children bad
advice they say things like why don't
you just stop using it
and so that facebook's own research is
aware that children express feelings of
loneliness and struggling with these
things because they can't even get
support from their own parents
i don't understand how facebook can know
all these things and not
escalate it to someone like congress for
help and support in navigating these
problems let me ask the question in a
broader way besides teenagers or besides
girls or besides youth are there other
practices at facebook or instagram that
are known to be harmful but yet are
pursued
um
[Music]
facebook is aware that choices are made
in establishing like meaningful social
meaningful social interactions so
engagement based ranking that didn't
care if you bullied someone or committed
hate speech in the comments that was
meaningful they know that that change
directly changed publishers behavior
that companies like buzzfeed wrote in
and said the content is most successful
on our platform is some of the content
we're most ashamed of you have a problem
with your ranking and they did nothing
they know that uh politicians are being
forced to take positions they know their
own constituents don't like or approve
of because those are the ones that get
distributed on facebook
that's a huge huge negative impact they
all facebook also knows that they have
admitted in public that engagement-based
ranking is dangerous without integrity
and security systems but then not rolled
out those integrity and security systems
to most of the languages in the world
and that's what causing things like
ethnic violence in ethiopia thank you
for your answer uh what is the magnitude
of facebook's revenues or profits
that come from uh the sale of user data
oh i'm i'm sorry i've never worked on
that i'm not aware thank you
um
what regulations or legal actions by
congress or by administrative action
do you think would have the most
consequence or would be feared most by
facebook instagram or allied companies
um i strongly encourage reforming
section 230 to um exempt
decisions about algorithms
right so
modifying 230 around content i think has
uh it's kind it's very complicated
because
user generated content is something that
companies have less control over they
have a hundred percent control over
their algorithms
and facebook should not get a free pass
on choices it makes to prioritize growth
and virality and reactiveness over
public safety
they shouldn't get a free pass on that
because they're paying for their profits
right now with our safety so i strongly
encourage reform of 230 in that way i
also believe there needs to be a
dedicated oversight body because right
now the only people in the world who are
trained to analyze these experiments to
understand what's happening inside of
facebook are people who you know grew up
inside of facebook or pinterest or
another social media company and there
needs to be a regulatory home where
someone like me could do a tour of duty
after working at a place like this
and and have a place to work on things
like regulation to bring that
information out to the oversight boards
that that have the right to do oversight
a regulatory agency within the federal
government yes
thank you very much thank you chairman
senator cantwell thank you mr chairman
thank you for holding this hearing and i
think my colleagues have brought up a
lot of important issues and so i think i
just want to continue on that vein
first of all the privacy act that i
introduced along with several of my
colleagues actually does have ftc
oversight of algorithm transparency in
some instances i'd hope you take a look
at that and tell us what other areas you
think
we should add to that level of
transparency but clearly that's the the
issue at hand here i think in your
coming forward so thank you again for
your willingness to do that
the documentation that you say now
exists
is uh the level of transparency about
what's going on that people haven't been
able to see
and so your information that you say has
gone up to the highest levels
at facebook is that they purposely knew
that their algorithms were continuing to
have misinformation and hate information
and that when presented with information
about this terminology uh you know
downstream msi meaningful social
information knowing that it was this
choice you could continue this
wrong-headed information hate
information about the rohingya or you
could continue to get higher
click-through rates and i know you said
you don't know about profits but i'm
pretty sure you know that on a page
if you click through that next page i'm
pretty sure there's a lot more ad
revenue than if you didn't click through
so you're saying that documents exist
that at the highest level
at facebook you had
information discussing these two choices
and that people chose even though they
knew that it was misinformation and
hurtful and maybe even causing people
lives they continue to choose profit
we have submitted documents to congress
outlining
mark zuckerberg was directly presented
with a list of quote soft interventions
so a hard intervention is like taking a
piece of content off facebook taking a
user off facebook soft interventions are
about making slightly different choices
to make the platform less viral less
twitchy
mark was presented with these options
and chose to not remove downstream msi
in april of 2020 even though he in
even just isolated in at-risk countries
that's countries at risk of violence
if it had any impact on the overall msi
metric so he chose which in translation
means less money yeah he he said right
was there another reason given why they
would do it other than they thought it
would really affect their numbers um
i don't don't know for certain like jeff
jeff horowitz the report for the wall
street journal i struggled with this we
sat there and read these minutes and
we're like how is this possible like
we've just read
100 pages on how downstream msi expands
hate speech misinformation violence and
citing content graphic violent content
why won't you get rid of this and we the
best theory that we've come up with and
i want to emphasize this is just our
interpretation on it is people's bonuses
are tied to msi
right like people people stay or leave
the company based on what they get paid
and like if you hurt msi a bunch of
people didn't weren't going to get their
bonuses so you're saying that this
practice even still continues today like
we're still in this environment i'm
personally
very frustrated by this because we
presented information to facebook from
one of my own constituents in 2018
talking about this issue with rohingya
pleading with the company we pleaded
with the company and they continue to
not address this issue now you're
pointing out that these same algorithms
are being used and they know darn well
in ethiopia that it's causing an
inciting violence and again they are
still today choosing profit over taking
this information down is that correct
when rioting began in the united states
in the summer of last year they turned
off downstream msi only for when they
detected content was health content
which is probably coveted and
civic content but facebook's own
algorithms are bad at finding this
content it's still in the raw form for
80 90 of of even that sensitive content
in countries where they don't have
integrity systems in the language local
language and in the case of ethiopia
there are 100 million people in ethiopia
in six languages
facebook only supports two of those
languages for integrity systems
this strategy of focusing on language
specific content specific systems ai to
save us is doomed to fail
i need to get to one of first of all i'm
sending a letter to facebook today they
better not delete any information as it
relates to the rohingya or
investigations about how they proceeded
on this particularly on in light of your
information or the documents but aren't
we also now talking about advertising
fraud aren't you selling something to
advertisers that's not really what
they're getting we know about this
because of the newspaper issues we're
trying to say that journalism that
basically has to meet a different
standard a public interest standard that
basically is out there basically proving
every day or they can be sued these guys
are a social media platform that doesn't
have to live with that and then the
consequences they're telling their
advertisers that this was the price we
see it we see it people are coming back
to the local journalism because they're
like we want to be again with the
trusted brand we don't want to be in you
know your website so i i think your
finding for the
sec
is an interesting one but i think that
we also have to look at what are the
other issues here and one of them is did
you defraud did they defraud advertisers
and telling them this was the
advertising content that you were going
to be advertising and when in reality it
was something different it was based on
a different model we have multiple
examples of
question and answers for the advertising
staff the sales staff where advertisers
say after the riots last summer we're
asked should we come back to facebook or
after the insurrection like should we
come back to facebook
and facebook said in their talking
points that they gave to advertisers
we're doing everything in our power to
make this safer or we take down all the
hate speech when we find it but
facebook's owning and that was not true
that was not true they get three to five
percent of hate speech thank you thank
you mr chairman thanks senator cantwell
um and if you want to make your letter
available to other members of the
committee i'd be glad to join you myself
thank you thank you for suggesting it
thank you um
senator lee
thank you mr chairman and thank you ms
haugen uh for joining us this week it's
very very helpful uh we're grateful that
you're willing to make yourself
available
last week we had another witness from
facebook
ms davis she came and she testified
before this committee and she focused on
among other things the extent to which
facebook targets ads to children
including ads that are either sexually
suggestive or geared toward adult themed
uh
products or themes in general
now i didn't i i appreciated her
willingness to be here i didn't
get the clearest answers
in response to some of those questions
and so i'm hoping that you can help shed
some light on some of those
issues related to facebook's advertising
processes here today as we get into this
i want to first read you a a quote uh
that i got from from ms davis last week
um here's what she said during her
questioning quote
when we do ads to young people there are
only three things that an advertiser can
target around age
gender location
we also prohibit certain ads to young
people including weight loss ads
we don't allow tobacco ads at all
meaning to young people we don't allow
them to children we don't allow them to
minors close quote
now since that exchange happened um last
week
uh there are a number of individuals and
groups including a group called the
technology transparency project or tdp
that have indicated that
that part of our testimony was
inaccurate that it was false
tdp noted that um
tdp had conducted an experiment
um
just last month
and their their goal was to
run a series of ads that
would be targeted to children ages 13 to
17 to users in the united states now i
want to emphasize that tdp didn't end up
running these ads
uh they stopped them from being
distributed to
to users
but facebook did in fact approve them
and as i understand it facebook approved
them for an audience of up to 9.1
million users all of whom were teens so
i brought a few of these to show you
today this is this is the first one i
wanted to showcase
this first one
has a colorful graphic
uh
encouraging kids to quote throw a
skittles party like no other
um which you know as the graphic
indicates and as as the slang jargon
uh also independently suggests
this involves
kids getting together
randomly to abuse prescription drugs
the second graphic displays
an anna tip
that is
a tip specifically designed to encourage
and promote
anorexia
and it's on there now the language the
anna tip itself
independently promotes that the ad also
promotes it insofar as it was suggesting
uh these are images you ought to look at
when you need motivation to be more
anorexic i guess you could say
um
now the third one invites children to
find their partner online and to make a
love connection you look lonely find
your partner now to make a love
connection now look it'd be an entirely
different kettle of fish if this were
targeted to an adult audience it is not
it's targeted to 13
to 17 year olds
now
obviously i don't support and and tdp
does not support these messages
particularly when targeted to
impressionable children
and and again just to be clear tdp did
not end up pushing the ads
out after receiving facebook's approval
but it did in fact receive facebook's
approval
um so i i think this says something one
could argue that it proves that facebook
is allowing
and and perhaps facilitating the
targeting of harmful adult-themed ads
to our nation's children
so could you
please explain to me ms haugen
how these ads
with a target audience
of 13 to 17 year old children
how would they possibly be approved by
facebook and is ai involved in that
um
i did not work directly on the ad
approval system um uh what was resonant
for me about your testimony is facebook
has a deep focus on scale so scale is
can we do things very cheaply for a huge
number of people which is part of why
they rely on ai so much it is very
possible that none of those ads were
seen by a human
and the reality is that we've seen from
repeated documents within my disclosures
is that facebook's ai systems only catch
a very tiny minority of offending
content and best case scenario in the
case of something like hate speech at
most they will ever get 10 to 20 percent
in the case of children that means drug
paraphernalia adds like that uh
it's likely if they rely on computers
and not humans they will also likely
never get more than 10 to 20 percent of
those ads understood mr chairman i've
got one minor follow-up question would
uh it should be easy to answer go ahead
um
so
well facebook may
claim
that it only targets ads
based on age gender and location
even though
these things uh seem to counteract that
but let's set that aside for a minute
and that they're not basing ads
based on specific interest categories
does facebook still collect
interest category data on teenagers
even if they aren't at that moment
targeting ads at
teens based on those interest categories
i think it's very important to
differentiate between what targeting are
advertisers allowed to specify and what
targeting facebook may learn for an ad
let's imagine you had some text on an ad
it would likely extract out features
that if thought was relevant for that ad
for example
in the case of something about partying
it would learn partying is a concept
i'm very suspicious that personalized
ads are still not being delivered
to teenagers on instagram because the
algorithms learn correlations they learn
interactions where your party ad may
still go to kids interested in partying
because facebook is prof is almost
certainly
has a ranking model in the background
that it says this person wants more
party related content
interesting uh thank you that's very
helpful and what that suggests to me is
that while they're they're saying
they're not targeting
teens with those ads the algorithm might
do some of that work for them which
might explain why they collect the data
even while claiming that they're not
targeting those ads in that way i can't
speak to whether or not that's the
intention but the reality is it's very
very very difficult to understand these
algorithms today and uh over and over
and over again we saw these biases the
algorithms unintentionally learn and so
yeah it's very hard to just disentangle
out these factors as long as you have
engagement based ranking thank you ms
halkin
thank you very much senator lee uh
senator uh marky
thank you mr chairman very much um
thank you miss hogan you you are a 21st
century american hero
warning our country of the danger
for young people
for our democracy and our nation owes
you
uh
a
just a huge
debt of gratitude for the courage you're
showing here today so thank you
um
miss hogan um do you agree that facebook
actively seeks to attract children and
teens onto its platforms
and facebook actively markets to
children or markets to children under
the age of 18 um to get on instagram and
definitely uh targets children as young
as eight to be on um
in messenger kids an internal facebook
document from 2020 that you reveal reads
why do we care about tweens they are a
valuable but untapped audience
so facebook only cares about children to
the extent that they are of monetary
value
last week facebook's global head of
safety
antigone
davis told me that facebook does not
allow targeting of certain harmful
content to teens miss davis stated we
don't allow weight loss ads to be shown
to people under the age of 18. yet a
recent study found that facebook
permitted targeting of teens as young as
13 with ads that showed a young woman's
thin waist promoting websites that
glorify anorexia ms hogan
based on your time at facebook do you
think facebook is telling the truth
i think facebook uh has focused on scale
over safety
and is likely that they are using um
artificial intelligence to try to
identify harmful ads without allowing
the public oversight to see what is the
actual effectiveness of those safety
systems you unearthed facebook's
research about its harm to teens did you
raise this issue with your supervisors
um i did not work directly on
anything involving teen mental health
this research was freely available to
anyone in the company
mr davis testified last week quote we
don't allow tobacco ads at all we don't
allow them
to children either we don't allow
alcohol ads to minors however
researchers also found that facebook
does allow targeting of teens with ads
on vaping
ms hogan based on your time at facebook
do you think facebook is telling the
truth
um i do not have context on that issue
um i assume that if they are using
artificial intelligence to catch those
vape ads unquestionably ads are making
its way through okay
um so from my perspective
listening to you and your incredibly
courageous revelations time and time
again facebook says one thing
and does another time and time again
facebook fails to abide by the
commitments that they had made time and
time again facebook lies about what they
are doing yesterday facebook had a
platform outage but for years it has had
a principles outage
its only real principle is profit
facebook's platforms are not safe for
young people as you said facebook is
like big tobacco
enticing young kids with that first
cigarette
that first social media account designed
to hook kids as users for life
ms hogan you know whistleblowing shows
that facebook uses harmful features that
quantify popularity push manipulative
influencer marketing amplify harmful
content to teens
and last week in this committee facebook
wouldn't even commit
to not using these features on 10 year
olds facebook is built on computer codes
of misconduct
senator blumenthal and i
have introduced the kids internet design
and safety act
the kids act
you have asked us
to act as a committee
and facebook has scores of lobbyists in
the city right now coming in
right after this hearing to tell us we
can't act
and have been successful for a decade
in blocking this committee from acting
so
let me ask you a question
the kids internet design and safety act
are the kids act here's what the
legislation does
it includes outright bans on children's
app features that one
quantify popularity with likes and
follow accounts
promotes two
that two promotes influencer marketing
and three that amplifies
a toxic post and that it would prohibit
facebook from using its algorithms to
promote toxic
post should we pass that legislation
i strongly encourage reforms that push
us towards human scale social media and
not computer-driven social media
those amplification harms are caused by
computers choosing what's important to
us not our friends and family and i
encourage any system that children are
exposed to to not use amplification
systems so you agree
that congress has to enact these special
protections for children and teens that
stop social media companies from
manipulating young users and threatening
their well-being to stop using its
algorithm to harm kids you agree with
that i i do believe congress must act
protect children
and children and teens also needed
privacy online bill of rights i'm the
author of the children's online privacy
protection act of 1998
but it's only for kids under 13 because
the industry stopped me from making at
age 16. in
1998 because it was already their
business model but we need to update
that law for the 21st century
tell me if this should pass one create
an online eraser button so that young
users can tell websites to delete the
data they've collected about them
to give young teens under the age of 16
and their parents control of their
information and three ban targeted ads
to children
i support all those actions thank you uh
and um and finally i've also introduced
the algorithmic justice
and online platform transparency act
which would one
open the hood
on facebook and big text algorithms so
we know how facebook
is using our data to decide what content
we see and two ban
discriminatory algorithms that harm
vulnerable populations online like
showing employment and housing ads to
white people but not to black
people in our country should congress
pass that bill
um algorithmic bias issues are a major
issue for our democracy um during my
time at pinterest i became very um
aware of the challenges of like i
mentioned before it's difficult for us
to understand how these algorithms
actually act and perform facebook is
aware of complaints today by people like
african americans saying that reals
doesn't give
african americans the same distribution
as white people and until we have
transparency and our ability to confirm
ourselves that facebook's marketing
messages are true we will not have a
system that is compatible with democracy
so i i i thank senator lee i agree with
you
in your line of questions i wrote
facebook asking them to explain that
discrepancy because facebook i think is
lying about targeting 13 to 15 year olds
so
here's my message for mark zuckerberg
your time
of invading our privacy promoting toxic
content and preying on children and
teens is over
congress will be taking action you can
work with us or not work with us but we
will not allow
your company to harm
our children
and our families and our democracy any
longer thank you mr hogan we will act
thanks senator markey uh we're gonna
turn to senator blackburn and then uh
we will take a break
uh
i know that
there's some interest in another round
of questions maybe
uh
well
uh maybe we'll turn to senator lujan
for his questions
uh cruz and scott and we have others so
we'll come back after the mr chairman
i have to um go to sit in the chair um
starting at noon today i don't uh we
turn
uh just
you have to i do i have one question
this relates to what mr markey was
asking
does facebook ever employ child
psychologists or mental health
professionals to deal with these
children online issues that we're
discussing
facebook has many researchers with phds
i assume some of them are
i know that some have psychology degrees
i'm not sure if they are child
specialists facebook also works with
external agencies that are specialists
at
children's rights online
senator lujan and then at the conclusion
of senator lujan's questions we'll take
a break we'll come back
at noon
thank you mr chairman and i appreciate
the indulgence of the committee
uh miss hogan last week the committee
heard directly from miss
davis the global head of safety for
facebook
during the hearing the company contested
their own
internal research as if it does not
exist
yes or no does facebook have internal
research indicating that instagram harms
teens
particularly harming perceptions of body
image which disproportionately affects
young women
yes facebook has extensive research on
the impacts of its products on teenagers
including young women thank you for
confirming these reports
last week i requested facebook make the
basis of this research the data set
minus any personally identifiable
information available to this committee
do you believe it is important for
transparency and safety that facebook
release the basis of this internal
research the core data set to allow for
independent analysis
i believe it is vitally important for
our democracy that we establish
mechanisms where facebook's internal
research must be disclosed to the public
on a regular basis and that we need to
have privacy sensitive data sets that
allow in independent researchers to
confirm whether or not facebook's
marketing messages are actually true
beyond this particular research should
facebook make its internal primary
research not just secondary slide decks
of cherry pick data but the underlying
data public by default can this be done
in a way that respects user privacy i
believe in collaboration with academics
and other researchers that we can
develop privacy conscious ways of
exposing radically more data that is
available today it is important for our
ability to understand how algorithms
work how facebook shapes the information
we get to see that we have these data
sets be publicly available for scrutiny
is facebook capable of making the right
decision here on its own or is
regulation needed to create real
transparency at facebook until
incentives change at facebook we should
not expect facebook to change we need
action from congress
last week i asked ms davis about shadow
profiles for children on the site and
she answered that no data is ever
collected on children under 13 because
they are not allowed to make accounts
this tactfully ignores the issue
facebook knows children use their
platform however instead of seeing this
as a problem to be solved facebook views
this as a business opportunity
yes or no does facebook conduct research
on children under 13 examining the
business opportunities of connecting
these young children to facebook's
products i want to emphasize how vital
it is that facebook should have to
publish the mechanisms by which it tries
to detect these children because they
are on the platform in far greater
numbers than anyone is aware
i do believe that or i am aware that
facebook is doing research on children
under the age of 13 and they have those
studies are included in my disclosure
you have shared your concerns about how
senior management at facebook has
continuously prioritized revenue over
potential user harm and safety and i
have a few questions on facebook's
decision making last week i asked ms
davis quote has facebook ever found a
change to its platform would potentially
inflict harm on users but facebook moved
forward because the change would also
grow users or increase revenue ms davis
said in response quote it's not been my
experience at all at facebook that's
just not how we would approach it yes or
no has facebook ever found a feature on
its platform harmed its users but the
feature moved forward because it would
also grow users or increase revenue
facebook likes to paint that these
issues are really complicated there are
lots of simple issues for example
requiring someone to click through on a
link before you reshare it that's not a
large imposition but it does decrease
growth a tiny little amount because in
some countries
reshares make up 35 of all the content
that people see
facebook prioritized that content on the
system the reshares over the impacts to
misinformation hate speech or violence
incitement
did these decisions ever come from mark
zuckerberg directly or from other senior
management at facebook
um we have a few choice documents that
contain notes from briefings with mark
zuckerberg where he chose um metrics
defined by facebook like meaningful
social interactions over changes that
would have significantly decreased
misinformation hate speech and other
inciting content and this is the
reference you shared earlier to ms
cantwell april of uh 2020. the soft
interventions
facebook appeared to be able to count on
the silence of its workforce for a long
time even as it knowingly continued
practices and policies that continue to
cause and amplify harm
facebook content moderators have called
out quote a culture of fear and secrecy
within the company that prevented them
from speaking out
is there a culture of fear at facebook
around whistleblowing and external
accountability
facebook has a culture that that that
emphasizes that that insularity is the
path forward that if information is
shared with the public it will just be
misunderstood
and i believe that relationship has to
change the only way that we will solve
these problems is by solving them
together and we will have much better
more democratic solutions if we do it
collaboratively than in isolation and my
final question is there a senior level
executive at facebook like an inspector
general who's responsible for ensuring
complaints from facebook employees are
taken seriously and that employees legal
ethical and moral concerns receive
consideration with the real possibility
of instigating change to company
policies um
i'm not aware of that role um but the
company is large and it may exist
i appreciate that it's my understanding
that
there's a gentleman by the name of roy
austin who is the vice president of
civil rights who's described himself as
an inspector general but he does not
have the authority to make these
internal conflicts public the oversight
board was created by facebook to review
moderation policies related to public
content specifically it was not created
to allow employees to raise concerns
so again another area of interest i
believe that we have to act on i thank
you for coming forward today
my pleasure
happy to serve
the committee is in recess
welcome back miss hogan thank you for
your patience uh we're going to
reconvene
and we'll go to senator hickenlooper
thank you mr chair thank you miss haugen
for
for your
direct answers and for being willing to
come out and
you know
provide such clarity on so many of these
issues
obviously facebook can manipulate its
algorithms to attract users
um
and i guess
my question would be do you feel
in your humble opinion that
you know simply
maximizing profits
no matter the societal impact that that
is justified
and i think
the question then would be that that's
the the short question which i think i
know the answer
what impact uh facebook's bottom line
would it have if the algorithm was
changed to promote
safety
and to
instead of
to for change to to
to save the lives of young women rather
than putting them at risk
i'm learning about the talk button
um facebook today uh
has a profit
makes approximately 40 billion dollars a
year in profit
a lot of the changes that i'm talking
about are are not going to make
facebook an unprofitable company it just
won't be a ludicrously profitable
company like it is today
engagement based ranking which causes
those amplification problems that leads
young women from you know innocuous
topics like healthy recipes to anorexia
content
if it were removed face people would
consume less content on facebook but
facebook would still be profitable and
so i i
encourage oversight and public scrutiny
into how these algorithms work and the
consequences of them
right well
and i appreciate that i uh i'm a former
small business owner i owned uh
uh started a brew pub back in 1988
and really was always we worked very
hard to to look
again we weren't doing investigations
but we were very sensitive to whether
someone had too much to drink whether we
had a frequent customer who was
frequently putting himself at risk and
and others
um
obviously i think the the facebook
business model puts uh
well poses risk to to youth into and to
teens uh you care compared to cigarette
companies which i thought was
rightfully so um
if this
i guess the question is is this level of
risk appropriate uh or
is there a level of risk that would be
appropriate i think there's an
opportunity to reframe some of these
oversight actions so when we think of
them as these trade-offs of like it's
either profitability or safety i think
that's a false choice
and then reality the thing i'm asking
for is a move from short termism which
is what facebook is run under today
right is being led by metrics and not
led by people
and that with appropriate oversight and
some of these constraints
it's possible that facebook actually a
much more profitable company five or ten
years down the road because it wasn't as
toxic not as many people quit it but
that's one of those counter factuals
that we can't actually test so
regulation might actually make facebook
more profitable over the long term right
that's often the case i think the same
could be set for automobiles and go down
the list
of all those things
that there's so much pushback in the
beginning um i also thought that the
um
the question of
of how do we assess the impact to their
bottom line
we had a representative facebook in here
recently who talked about that eight out
of ten uh facebook users feel their life
is better and that their job is to get
to ten out of ten
maybe this is the two to twenty percent
that they're missing i don't know how
large that the demographic is of of
people that are caught back up into this
circus uh circuitous uh you know
sense of of really taking them down into
the wrong direction how many people that
is do you have any idea
um
that quote last week was really shocking
to me because i don't know if you're
aware of this but in the case of
cigarettes
uh only about 10 of people who smoke
ever get lung cancer
right um so the idea that you know 20 of
your users could be facing uh serious
mental health issues and that's not a
problem is shocking um i also want to
emphasize for people that that eating
disorders are serious right they're
going to be women walking around this
planet in 60 years with brittle bones
because of choices that facebook made
around emphasizing profit today or
they're going to be women
in 20 years who want to have babies who
can't because they're infertile as a
result of eating disorders today they're
serious
and i think there's an opportunity here
for having public oversight and public
involvement especially in matters that
impact children
great well thank you for being so direct
on this and for stepping forward i yield
back the floor chair
thanks senator hickenlooper senator cruz
thank you mr chairman ms hogan welcome
thank you for your testimony
uh when it concerns facebook there are a
number of concerns that this committee
and congress has been focused on two of
the biggest have been facebook's
intentional targeting of kids
with content that is harmful to the
children
and then secondly in a discrete issue is
the pattern of facebook and social media
engaging in political censorship
i want to start with the first issue
targeting kids
as you're aware and as indeed the
documents that you provided indicated
facebook
according to the public reporting on it
facebook's
internal reports found that instagram
makes quote body image issues worse
for one in three teen girls
and additionally it showed that quote
thirteen percent of british users
and six percent of american users
trace their desire to kill themselves to
instagram
uh is that a fair and accurate
characterization of what facebook's
research concluded
um i only know what i read in the
documents that were included in my
disclosure um that is that is an
accurate description of the ones that i
have read i
because facebook has not come forward
with the total corpus of their known
research i don't know what their other
things say but yes there is documents
that say those things so we had
testimony last week in the senate with a
witness from facebook who claimed that
that uh that information was not
accurate and needed to be in context now
of course she wasn't willing to provide
the context the alleged mysterious
context do you know of any context
that would make those data anything
other than horrifying and deeply
disturbing
um
engagement based ranking and these
processes of amplification
they they impact all users of facebook
the algorithms are very smart in the
sense that they latch on to things that
people want to continue to engage with
and unfortunately in the case of teen
girls and things like self-harm they
develop these feedback cycles where
children are using instagram as to
self-soothe but then are exposed to more
and more content that makes them hate
themselves
this is a thing where we can't say 80
percent of kids are okay we need to say
how do we save all the kids
the wall street journal reported that
mark zuckerberg was personally aware of
this research do you have any
information one way or the other as to
mr zuckerberg's awareness of the
research um we have a uh excuse me um
one of the documents included in the
disclosures it details something called
project daisy which is an initiative to
remove likes off of instagram the
internal research showed that removing
likes off instagram is not effective as
long as you leave comments on those
posts and yet the research directly
presented to mark zuckerberg said we
should still pursue this as a feature to
launch even though it's not effective
because the government journalists and
academics want us to do this like it
would get us positive points to the
public
that that kind of duplicity is why we
need to have more transparency and why
if we want to have a system that is
coherent with democracy we must have
public oversight from congress
do you know if facebook any of the
research it conducted attempted to
quantify how many teenage girls may have
taken their lives because of facebook's
products
i am not aware of that research
do you know if facebook made any changes
when they got back that 13 of british
users and six percent of american users
traced their desire to kill themselves
to instagram do you know if they made
any changes
in response to that research to try to
correct or mitigate that i found it very
surprising that when antonia davis was
confronted with this research last week
she couldn't enumerate a five-point plan
a 10-point plan of the actions that they
took i also find it shocking that one
once facebook had this research it
didn't disclose it to the public because
this is the kind of thing that should
have oversight from congress
so when you were at facebook were there
discussions about how to respond to this
this research um i did not work directly
on uh issues concerning children these
are just documents that were freely
available in the company so i am not
aware of that okay
do you have thoughts as to what kind of
changes facebook could make
to reduce or eliminate these harms
you mentioned earlier concerns around
free speech a lot of the things that i
advocate for are around changing the
mechanisms of amplification not around
picking winners and losers in the
marketplace of ideas the problem explain
what that means oh sure um so like i
mentioned before you know like how on
twitter if you have to click through on
a link before you re-share it
small actions like that friction
don't require picking good ideas and bad
ideas they just make the platform less
twitchy less reactive and facebook's
internal research says that each one of
those small actions
dramatically reduces misinformation hate
speech and violence inciting content on
the platform so and we're running out of
time but but on the second major topic
of concern of facebook which is
censorship based on what you've seen are
you are you concerned about political
censorship at facebook and in big tech
i believe you cannot have a system that
uh
has as big an impact on society as
facebook does today with as little
transparency as it does
i am a strong proponent of chronological
ranking or ordering by time with a
little bit of spammed emotion because i
think
um
we don't want computers deciding what we
focus on we should have software that is
human scaled where humans have
conversations together not computers
facilitating who we get to hear from so
how could we get more transparency what
would produce that
um i strongly encourage the development
of some kind of regulatory body that
could
work with academics work with
researchers work with other government
agencies to
synthesize requests for data that are
privacy conscious this is an area that
i'm really passionate about
and because right now no one can force
facebook to disclose data and facebook
has been stonewalling us or even worse
they gave inaccurate data to researchers
as the scandal recently showed what data
should they turn over and my time is
expired so um
for example um
even data as simple as what integrity
systems exist today and how well do they
perform
like there are lots and lots of people
who facebook is conveying around the
world that that facebook safety systems
apply to their language and those people
aren't aware that they're using a raw
original dangerous version of facebook
just basic actions like transparency
would make a huge difference okay thank
you
thanks senator cruz senator loomis
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony um
if you were in my seat today instead of
your seat
what documents or unanswered questions
would you seek
from facebook especially as it relates
to children
but even generally speaking
i think any research regarding what
facebook does problematic use i.e the
addictiveness of the product is of vital
importance and anything around what
facebook knows about
parents lack of knowledge about the
platform
i only know about the documents that i
have seen right i did not work on teens
or child safety myself but in the
documents that i read facebook
articulates the idea that parents today
are not aware of how dangerous instagram
is and they because they themselves did
not live through these experiences they
can't coach their kids on basic safety
things
and so at a minimum facebook shaft to
disclose what it knows in that context
okay so we're trying to protect
individuals data that they're gathering
have data privacy
but have transparency
uh in the manner in which
the data is used
can we bridge that gap
imagine um i i think we reasonable
people can have a conversation on how
many people need to see a piece of
content before it's not really private
like if a hundred thousand people see
something is it private if 25 000 people
see it is it private just disclosing the
most popular content on the platform
including statistics around what factors
went into the promotion of that content
would cause radically more transparency
than we have today on how facebook
chooses what we get to focus on how they
shape our reality
okay if if our focus is protecting the
first amendment and our rights to free
speech while
very carefully regulating
um
data privacy
um
i've heard there there are a number of
things that are being discussed in
congress everything from
um
antitrust laws
to
uh calling facebook a utility
to
the idea that you just raised of a
regulatory board of some sort
that has authority to
through understanding of the algorithms
and how they're used and other uh
mechanisms that create what we see
the
the face of facebook so to speak um
tell me a little more about how you
envisioned that board working
what is the in your mind based on your
understanding of the company and the ill
um
consequences uh what is the best
approach to bridging the gap between
keeping speech free
and protecting individual privacy with
regard to data
so i think those issues are
they are independent issues so we can
talk about free speech first which is
having more transparency like facebook
has solutions today that are not
content-based and i am a strong advocate
for non-content-based solutions because
those solutions will also then protect
the most vulnerable people in the world
in a place like ethiopia where they
speak six languages
if you have something that focuses on
good ideas and bad ideas those systems
don't work in diverse places so
investing in
non-content-based ways to slow the
platform down not only protects our
freedom of speech it protects people's
lives the second question is around
privacy and this question of how can we
have oversight and have privacy there is
lots and lots of research on how to
abstract data sets so you're not showing
people's names you might not even be
showing the content of their post you
might be showing data that is about the
content of their post but not the post
itself there are many ways to structure
these data sets that are privacy
conscious and be the fact that facebook
has walled off the ability to see even
basic things about how the platform
performs or in the case of their past
academic research releasing inaccurate
data
or not being clear about how they pulled
that data is just part of a pattern of
behavior of facebook hiding behind walls
and operating in the shadows and they
have far too much power in our society
to be allowed to continue to operate
that way
well i i had heard you make the analogy
earlier to the tobacco industry and i
think that that's an appropriate analogy
um i
i really believe we're searching for
the best way
to address the problem
and i'm i i'm not sure that it is the
heavy hands like breaking up
companies or um
calling them a utility
which is why your approach
of integrating people who understand
the math and the uses of the math
with
protecting
privacy is intriguing to me
so the more
information that you can provide to us
about how that might work to actually
address the problem
i i think would be helpful so um in my
case this is an invitation to you
uh to
provide to my office or the committee um
information about how we can get at the
root of the problem that you've
identified and can document
and
save people's privacy
so
i extend that invitation to you and i
thank you for your testimony mr chairman
i yield back thanks senator lomas uh
senator sullivan
thank you mr chairman and
i want to thank our witness here uh it's
been a good hearing a lot of information
has been learned
particularly on the issue of how this is
impacting our kids
i think
we're going to look back
20 years from now
and
all of us are going to be like what in
the hell were we thinking when we
recognize
the damage that it's done to a
generation
of kids do you agree with that mrs hugin
uh when facebook made statement has made
statements in the past about how much
benefit
instagram is providing to kids mental
health like kids are connecting who are
once alone
uh
what i'm so surprised about that is if
if instagram is such a positive force
what have we have we seen a golden age
of teenage mental health in the last 10
years no we've seen i've seen the
opposite right we've seen escalating
rates of suicide and depression amongst
teenagers do you think those rates are
at least in part driven by the social
media phenomena there is a broad swath
of research that supports the idea that
usage of social media uh
amplifies the risk for these mental
health harms right now and this hearing
is helping illuminate it yeah we are
seeing and facebook's on research shows
up right yeah say that again that's what
i said and facebook's own research shows
up
right the kids are saying kids are
saying i am unhappy when i use instagram
and i can't stop that if i leave i'm
afraid i'll be ostracized right and
that's that's so sad
so they know that
that's what their research shows
so what do you think drives them to i
had this discussion with the witness
last week
and i said well
you know i think they called it their
time out or
stop i said but isn't that incompatible
with your business model because your
business model is more time online more
eyeballs online isn't that
the fundamental elements of their
business model
facebook has had both an interesting
opportunity and a hard challenge from
being a closed system
so they have had the opportunity to hide
their problems and like often people do
when they can hide their problems they
get in over their heads and i think
facebook needs an opportunity to have
congress step in and say guess what you
don't have to struggle by yourself
anymore you don't have to hide these
things from us you don't have to pretend
they're not problems you can declare
moral bankruptcy and we can figure out
how to fix these things together because
we solve problems together we don't
solve them alone and by moral bankruptcy
one of the things that i appreciate the
phrase that the chairman and you've been
using
is one of those elements which is they
know this is a problem they know it's
actually
impacting negatively the mental health
of the most precious assets we have in
america our youth our kids i have three
daughters
um
they know that that is happening and yet
the moral bankruptcy
from your perspective is the continued
the continuation of this simply because
that's how they make money i i phrase it
slightly differently we have financial
bankruptcy because we value people's
lives more than we value money right the
people get in over their heads and they
need a process where they admit they did
something wrong but we have a mechanism
where we forgive them and we have a way
for them to move forward facebook is
stuck in a feedback loop that they
cannot get out of they have been hiding
this information because they feel
trapped right like they would have come
forward if they had solutions to these
things they need to admit they did
something wrong and they need help to
solve these problems and that's what
moral bankruptcy is let me ask i'm going
to switch gears here and and this is uh
you what's your current position right
now in terms of its disinformation and
counter espionage um my last role at
facebook was in counter space i'm sorry
your last role okay yeah
so one of the things this is a very
different topic and um
i only got a minute or so left but
right now is facebook i know facebook is
not allowed in countries like china
but do they provide
platforms for authoritarian or
terrorists based
leaders
like
the ayatollahs in iran that's the
largest state-sponsored terrorism in the
world
or the taliban
or xi jinping our certain my view our
biggest rival for this century
a communist
party dictator who's trying to export
his authoritarian model
around the world
do they provide a platform for those
kind of um
leaders who
in my view clearly don't hold america's
interests uh in mind
because facebook provided
i during my time working with the threat
intelligence org so i was a product
manager supporting the threat of the
counter-espionage team
my team directly worked on
tracking chinese participation on the
platform surveilling say weaker
populations uh in places around the
world that you could actually find the
chinese based on them doing these kinds
of things so facebook yeah i'm sorry um
we also saw
active persuasion of say the iran
government doing espionage on other
state actors
so this is definitely thing that is
happening and i believe facebook's
consistent understaffing of the
counter-espionage information operations
and counter-terrorism teams is a
national security issue and i'm speaking
to other parts of congress about that so
you are saying in essence that the
the platform whether facebook knows it
or not is being utilized by some of our
adversaries in a way that helps push and
promote
their interests at the expense of
americas yes facebook's so very aware
that this is happening on the platform
and i believe the fact that congress
doesn't get a report of exactly how many
people are working on these things
internally is is unacceptable because
you have a right to keep the american
people safe
great thank you very much
thanks senator sullivan uh you may have
just opened
an area for another year sorry yeah
yeah i've i've strong national security
concerns about how facebook operates
today well mr chairman maybe we should
right i mean it's a i'm
not being at all facetious
thank you for your questions on this
topic and i know you have a busy
schedule but we may want to
discuss this issue with you members of
our committee at least informally and if
you'd be willing to come back for
another hearing
that uh certainly is within the realm of
possibility i haven't consulted the
ranking member but
uh or the chair
woman but um
thank you for your honesty and your
candor on that topic
uh senator scott
thank you chairman um first off thanks
for coming forward and thanks for coming
forward in the matter that you wanted to
have a have positive change so that's
not always what what happens
earlier this year i sent a letter to
facebook and other social media
platforms asking them to detail the
harmful impacts the effects on mental
health their platforms have on
children and teens so your reports
reveal that facebook has been clearly
fully aware of this
for a while
um and the harmful impacts especially on
young women so i think we all agree
that's completely unacceptable
and we've got to figure out how we
protect
the people that are vulnerable in this
country from the harmful impacts of
facebook and other social media
platforms
so first off do you think there should
be
a greater consideration for age when it
comes to using any social media
i strongly encourage raising age limits
to 16 or 18 years old based on
looking at the data around
problematic use or addiction on the
platform and
children's self-regulation issues
so
so i think you addressed this a little
bit but why do you think
uh facebook didn't address this publicly
when they they figured out internally
that they were having an adverse impact
on
young young people especially young
women why didn't they come forward and
say
i've got we've got a problem we got to
figure this out i i have a huge amount
of empathy for for facebook these are
really really hard questions um and part
of why i'm saying i think i think they
feel a little a little trapped and
isolated is
the problems that are driving uh
negative social comparison on instagram
facebook's own research says
instagram is actually distinctly worse
than say tick tock or snapchat or reddit
because instagram tic talk is about
doing fun things with your friends
snapchat is about faces and augmented
reality uh reddit is vaguely about ideas
but instagram is about bodies and about
comparing lifestyles
and so i think there are real questions
where like instagram would have to come
in and think hard about their product or
about like what is their product about
and i think i don't think those answers
are immediately obvious that's why i
believe we need to solve problems
together and not alone because
collaborating with the public will give
us better solutions
so do you think facebook was trying to
trying to mitigate the problem
i think within the set of incentives
that they were working within they did
the best they could unfortunately those
incentives are not sustainable and they
are not acceptable uh in in our society
do you think facebook and other social
media platforms ought to be able to be
required to report any harmful effects
they have on young people
uh one of the things that i found uh
very interesting after the report in the
wall street journal on teen mental
health was that a a former executive at
the company said facebook needs to be
able to have private research and the
part that i was offended by this was
facebook has had some of this research
on the negative effects of instagram on
teenagers for years
i strongly support the idea that
facebook should have a year maybe 18
months to have private research but
given that they are the only people in
the world who can do this kind of
research
that the public never gets to do it they
shouldn't be allowed to keep secrets
when people's lives are on the line
so
because because to be clear if they make
40 billion dollars a year they have the
resources to solve these problems
they're choosing not to solve them yeah
did that surprise you they wouldn't put
more effort into this no because you
know it's going to catch up with them
eventually right yeah
like i mentioned earlier to senator
hickenlooper
right coming in and having oversight
might actually make facebook a more
profitable company five or ten years
from now because toxicity facebook's own
research shows uh they have something
called an integrity holdout these are
people who don't get protections from
integrity systems to see what happens to
them
and those people who deal with a more
toxic painful version of facebook use
facebook less
and so one could could
could reason
a kinder friendlier more collaborative
facebook might actually have more users
five years from now so it's in in
everyone's interest do you think i've
got a bill and there's a lot of bills
that i think we've all talked about but
mine is called the data act it's going
to require express consent from users
for large platforms to use algorithms on
somebody you agree with that
i mean i mean what shouldn't we consent
before they get to take our on
everything about us and go sell it
i think how they send things to us for
for um selling personal data that uh
that is an issue i believe people should
have substantially more control over um
uh most people are not well informed on
what the cost the cost personal costs of
having their data sold are and so i
worry about
pushing that choice back on individual
consumers
in terms of should people consent to
working with algorithms
i worry that if facebook is allowed to
give users the choice of do you want an
engagement based news feed or do you
want a chronological news feed like
ordered by time maybe a little spammed
emotion
that people will choose the more
addictive option that engagement based
ranking even if it is leading their
their daughters to eating disorders
all right thank you
thanks senator scott i think we have
concluded the first round
unless we're missing someone who is
on line
and
not hearing anyone uh let's go to the
second round
uh thank you again for your patience uh
i know you have a hard stop i think at 1
30.
so we'll be respectful of that
limitation and
i'll begin by asking a few questions
first let me say
senator klobuchar
very
aptly
raised with you
the principal obstacle to our achieving
legislative reform in the past which is
the
tons of
money
spent on lobbyists and other
kinds of
influence peddling
to use a pejorative word that is so
evident here in the united states
congress
some of it's dark money some of it is
very overt
but
i guess the point i'd like to make to
you personally is that your being here
really
sends a profound message to
our nation that one person can really
make a difference
one person standing up speaking out
can overcome
a lot of those obstacles for us and you
have crystallized
in a way our
consciousness here you have
been a catalyst i think for change in a
way that
we haven't seen and i've been working on
these issues for
10 15 years
and you have raised awareness in a way
that i think is very unique
so
uh thank you not only for your risk
taking and your
courage and strength in standing up but
also
for the effect that it has had
uh and i also want to make another point
you can tell me whether i'm correct or
not
i think there are other whistleblowers
out there
i think there are other truth tellers
in the tech world
who want to come forward and i think
you're
leading by example
i think you are showing them that
there's a path to make this industry
more responsible
and
more caring about kids
and about the nature of our public
discourse generally and about the
strength of our democracy and i think
you
have given them
a boost
those whistleblowers out there
in potentially coming forward i think
that's tremendously important i think
also
and again you can tell me if i'm wrong
there are a lot of people on facebook
who are cheering for you
because
they're public reports and i know of
some of my
friends in this world who tell me
that
they're people working for facebook who
wish
they had
the opportunity and the courage to come
forward as you have done because they
feel
a lot of reservations about the way that
facebook has used the platform used
algorithms
used
content and pushed it on kids in this
way
so
those are sort of hypotheses
uh
that i hope you can confirm
um and i also would like to ask you
because a lot of parents are watching
right now
so you've advised us
on what you think we should do the
reforms some of them that you think we
should adopt stronger oversight
authorized by congress
better disclosure
because right now
facebook essentially is a black box yes
for most of america facebook is a black
box
that's designed by mark zuckerberg
incorporated
mark zuckerberg and
his immediate codery
and the buck stops with him
and
reform of section 203 so there's some
legal responsibility so people have a
day in court some kind of recourse
legally when they're harmed by facebook
because right now it has this broad
immunity most of america has no idea
essentially you can't sue
facebook
you have no recourse
most america doesn't know about section
230
and
if you
push
a lot of members of congress they
wouldn't know either
it's actually slightly worse than that
they uh facebook made a statement in a
legal proceeding recently where they
said they had the right to mislead the
court because they had immunity
right that 230 give them immunity so why
should they have to tell the truth about
what they're showing
which is
kind of
shocking
well it is shocking to a lawyer yeah
which some of us are
uh it's also
utter
disregard and contempt for the rule of
law and for the very legal structure
that gives them
that kind of protection so
it's
kind of a new low in
corporate
conduct at least in court
uh
so you've you provided us with some of
the reforms that you think
are
important and i think that the oversight
goes a long way because it in turn would
make public
uh a lot of what is going on
in this black box
but for now
since a lot of teens and
tweens will be going home tonight
as you said
to endure the bullying
the eating disorders
the invitations to
[Music]
feel insecure about themselves
heightened anxiety they have to live
with the real world as it exists right
now
and they will be
haunted
for their lifetimes by these experiences
what would you tell parents
right now
what would you advise them
about what they can do because they need
more tools
and some of the proposals that have been
mentioned here would give parents
more tools to protect their children
right now a lot of parents tell me
they
feel powerless
they need more information they're
way behind their kids and their
adeptness online
and
they feel that
they need to be empowered
in some way to protect their kids in the
real world right now
in real time so i
offer you that
open-ended opportunity to
talk to us a little bit about your
thoughts
very rarely do you have one of these
generational shifts where uh the the
generation that leads like parents who
who who guide their children
have such um a different set of
experiences that they don't have the
context to support their children in a
safe way
um there is an active need for schools
or or maybe the
national institutes of health to to make
established information where if parents
want to learn how they can support their
kids it should be easy for them to know
what is constructive and not
constructive
because
facebook's own research says kids today
feel like they are struggling alone with
all these issues
because their parents can't guide them
and one of the things i'm sad is when i
look on twitter is when people blame the
parents for these problems with facebook
they say just take your kid's phone away
and the reality is those issues are a
lot more complicated than that um and so
we need to support parents because right
now if facebook won't protect the kids
we at least need to help the parents to
protect the kids
if parents are anguished they are
about this issue parents are hardly
uncaring they
need the tools they need to be empowered
and
i think that the
major encouragement for reforms is going
to come from
those parents
and
you have pointed out i think in general
but i'd like you to just confirm for me
uh
this research
and the documents containing that
research
is not only findings and conclusions
also recommendations for changes
what i hear you saying is that again and
again and again
these recommendations were just rejected
or disregarded correct
there is a pattern of behavior that i
saw at facebook of facebook choosing to
prioritize its profits over people
and any time that facebook faced even
tiny hits to growth like point one
percent of sessions
one percent of of views that it shows
its profits over safety and you
mentioned i think bonuses tied to
downstream msis decor msi yeah could you
explain what you meant um so msi is
meaningful social interaction
facebook's internal governance is very
much based around metrics so facebook is
incredibly flat to the point where they
have the largest open floor plan office
in the world it's a quarter of a mile
long and one room right they believe in
flat
and instead of having internal
governance they have metrics that people
try to move
in a world like that it doesn't matter
that we now have multiple years of data
saying msi may be encouraging bad
content might be making
spaces where people are are scared where
they are shown information that puts
them at risk
it's so hard to dislodge a ruler like
that
that a yardstick
that
you end up in a situation where because
no one is taking leadership like no one
is intentionally designing these systems
it's just many many people running in
parallel all moving the metric that
these problems get amplified and
amplified and amplified and no one steps
in to bring the solutions
i just want to finish and then i think
we've been joined by senator young
um
and then we'll go
to
senator blackburn and senator klobuchar
um
you know i spent a number of years as an
attorney general helping to lead
litigation against big tobacco
and
i came to
hear from a lot of
smokers
how grateful they were
ironically and unexpectedly that someone
was fighting big tobacco because they
felt they had been victimized as
children
they started smoking when they were 7 8
12 years old because big tobacco was
hooking them
and as we developed the research very
methodically and purposefully
addicting them
at that early age when
they
believed
that
they
would make themselves more popular
that they would be cool and hip if they
began smoking and then nicotine
hooked them now physiologically
nicotine has addictive properties
what is it about
facebook's tactics
of hooking young people
that makes it similar to what
big tobacco
has done
facebook's own research about instagram
contains quotes from kids saying
i feel bad when i use instagram
but i also feel like i can't stop right
i i know that the more time i spend on
this the worse i feel but like i just
can't like that they want the next click
they want the next like they they the
the dopamine the little hits all the
time
and
i i feel a lot of pain for those kids
right like they they they say they fear
being ostracized if they step away from
the platform so imagine you're in the
situation in this relationship where
every time you open the app it makes you
feel worse but you also fear
isolation if you don't
i think there's a huge opportunity here
to make social media that makes kids
feel good not feel bad
and that we have an obligation to our
youth to make sure that they're safe
online
thank you uh senator young
um uh thank you for your compelling
testimony
in that testimony you discuss how
facebook generates self-harm and and
self-hate
especially among vulnerable groups like
teenage girls
i happen to be a father of four kids um
three daughters two of whom are
teenagers and um as you as you just
alluded to most adults myself included
i've never been a teenager
during the age of facebook instagram and
these other social media platforms
and therefore i think it can be really
hard
for many of us to fully appreciate the
impact that certain posts may have
uh in including i would add
on a teen's mental health
so can you discuss the short and
long-term consequences of body image
issues
on these platforms please
the patterns that children establish in
their teenage years live with them for
the rest of their lives the way they
conceptualize who they are how they
conceptualize how they interact with
other people are patterns and habits
that they will take with them as they
become adults as they themselves raise
children
i'm very scared about the upcoming
generation because
when you and i interact in person and i
say something mean to you and i see you
wince or i see you cry
that makes me less likely to do it the
next time right that's a feedback cycle
online kids don't get those cues
and they learn to be incredibly cruel to
each other and they normalize it
and i'm scared of what will their lives
look like where they grow up with the
idea that it's okay to be treated badly
by people who who allegedly care about
them that's a scary future
very scary future
and i see some evidence of of that as to
so many parents
um on a on a regular basis are are there
other specific issues of
significant consequence that the general
public may not be fully aware of that
are impacting um vulnerable groups that
you you just like to elevate
during this testimony
one of the things that's hard
for people who don't look at the data of
social networks every day it can be hard
to conceptualize the distribution
patterns of harms or just of usage that
there are these things called power laws
it means that a small number of users
are extremely intensely engaged on any
given topic and most people are just
lightly engaged
when you look at things like
misinformation facebook knows that the
people who are exposed to the most
misinformation are people who are
recently widowed divorced moved to a new
city
are isolated in some other way
when i worked on civic misinformation we
discussed the idea of the misinformation
burden like the idea that when people
are exposed to ideas that are not true
over and over again it erodes their
ability to to connect with the community
at large because they no longer adhere
to facts that are consensus reality
the fact that facebook knows that it's
most vulnerable users people who
recently widowed like that they're
isolated that that the systems that are
meant to keep them safe like demoting
misinformation stop working when people
look at 2000 posts a day
right and i just it breaks my heart the
idea that these rabbit holes would suck
people down and then make it hard to
connect with others
so miss miss hajin
i desperately want to
uh which is the american impulse i want
to solve this problem
and
uh i very much uh believe that uh
congress not only has a role but has a
responsibility to
figure this out
i don't pretend to have all the answers
i would value your
opinion though
as to whether you believe that breaking
up facebook would solve any of the
problems that you've discussed today you
think it would
so as an algorithmic specialist so this
is someone who designs algorithmic
experiences i'm actually against the
breaking up of facebook because even
looking inside of just facebook itself
so not even facebook and instagram you
see the problems of engagement based
ranking repeat themselves
so the problems here are about the
design of algorithms of ai and the idea
that ai is not intelligent
and if you break up instagram and
facebook from each other it's likely so
i used to work on pinterest
and the thing that we faced from a
business model perspective was that
advertisers didn't want to learn
multiple advertising platforms
that they wanted to learn they got one
platform for instagram and facebook and
whatever and learning a second one for
pinterest
pinterest made radically fewer dollars
per user and what i'm scared of is right
now facebook is the internet for lots of
the world if you go to africa the
internet is facebook if you split
facebook and instagram apart it's likely
that most advertising dollars will go to
instagram and facebook will continue to
be this frankenstein that is altering
like that is endangering lives around
the world only now there won't be money
to fund it
and so i think oversight and regulat
oversight and um
finding collaborative solutions with
congress is going to be key because
these systems are going to continue to
exist and be dangerous even if broken up
thank you
thank you
senator blackburn
thank you mr chairman
uh
i have a text that was just put up by
facebook spokesperson angela stone
it says just pointing out the fact that
uh francis hogan did not work on child
safety or instagram or research these
issues and has no direct knowledge of
the topic from her work at facebook
so i will simply say this to mr stone if
facebook wants to discuss their
targeting of children
if they want to discuss
their practices
of
privacy invasion or violations of the
children online privacy act i am
extending to you an invitation to step
forward be sworn in and testify
before this committee we would be
pleased to hear from you and welcome
your testimony
um
one quick question for you what's the
biggest threat to facebook's existence
is it greed
is it
regulators is it becoming
extinct or obsolete for teenage
users what is the biggest threat to
their existence
i think the fact that facebook is driven
so much by metrics and that these lead
to a very heavy emphasis on
short-termism
that every little individual decision
may seem like it helps with growth but
if it makes it more and more toxic
platform that people don't actually
enjoy like when they passed meaningful
social interact meaningful social
interactions back in 2018 facebook's own
research said that users said it made it
less meaningful
right i think this
aggregated set of short-term decisions
endangers facebook's future
okay but sometimes we need to pull it
away from
business as usual help it write new
rules if we wanted to be successful in
the future so they can't see the forest
for the yes yes
very cute
and i know senator klobuchar is waiting
so i'll yield my time back and i thank
you thanks senator blackburn
thank you very much and thank you to
both of you for your leadership and all
three of us are on the judiciary
committee so we're also working on a
host of other
issues including
the app store issues
which is unrelated to facebook actually
including issues relating to
dominant platforms when they promote
their own content or engage in
exclusionary conduct which i know is not
our topic today i see the thumbs up from
you ms hogan which i appreciate
i think this idea of establishing some
rules of the road
for these tech platforms um goes beyond
the kid protection that we so dearly
need to do and i just want to make sure
you agree with me on that totally uh i
was shocked when i saw the new york
times story a couple weeks ago about
facebook using its own platform to
promote positive news about itself
i was like wow
i knew you shaped our reality i wasn't
aware it was that much right and that's
a lot of the work uh that we're doing
over there so i want to get to something
senator young was talking about
misinformation and
senator lujan and i have put together a
an exception actually to the 230
immunity when it comes to
vaccine misinformation in the middle of
a public health crisis
last week youtube announced it was
swiftly banning all anti-vaccine uh
misinformation and i've long called on
facebook to take similar steps they've
take taken some steps um but do you
think they can remove this content and
do that they put sufficient
gotten the vaccines it's because
you know the guy i walked into a cafe
and said his mother-in-law wouldn't get
a vaccine because she thought a
microchip would be planted in her arm
could you
which is false i'm just saying that for
the record here um could in case it gets
put on social media could you uh talk
about are there
are there enough resources to stop this
from happening
um i do not believe facebook ad is
currently structured has the capability
to stop vaccine misinformation because
they are overly reliant on artificial
intelligence systems that they
themselves say will likely never get
more than 10 to 20 of content there you
go
and yet it's a company that what the cap
over a trillion dollars from the world's
biggest companies that we've ever known
and that's what really bothers me here
uh senator lujan and i also have pointed
out
the issue with content moderators does
facebook have enough content moderations
for content in spanish and other
languages besides english
um one of the things that was disclosed
uh
we have we have documentation that shows
how much operational investment there
was by different languages and it showed
a consistent pattern of under investment
in languages that are not english
um i am deeply concerned about
facebook's ability to operate in a safe
way in languages beyond maybe the top 20
in the world okay thank you
we go back to eating disorders today
you've said that you have documents
indicating facebook is doing studies on
kids under 13 even though technically no
kids under 13 are permitted on the
platform
uh the potential for eating disorder
content to be shown to these children
raises serious concern senator
blumenthal's been working on this i've
long been focused on this eating
disorder issue given the mortality rates
are you aware of studies facebook has
conducted about whether kids under 13
under 13 on the platform are nudged
towards content related to eating
disorders or unhealthy diet practices
cnn also did investigation on this front
i have not seen specific studies
regarding
eating disorders in under the age of 13
but i have seen research that indicates
that they are aware
that teenagers coach tweens who are on
the platform
to not reveal too much
to um not post too often and that they
have categorized that as a myth that you
can't be authentic on the platform
and that the marketing team should talk
should try to advertise to teenagers to
stop coaching tweens that way
um so we i believe we've shared that
document with congress exactly well
thank you and we'll be looking more
speaking of the research issue
um facebook has tried to downplay uh the
internal research that was done saying
it was unreliable reliable
um it seems to me that they're trying to
mislead us there the research was
extensive surveying hundreds of
thousands of people traveling around the
world to interview users in your view
are the
internal researchers at facebook who
examine how users are affected by the
platform
is their work thorough um are they
experienced is it fair for facebook to
throw them under the bus
facebook has one of the top ranked
research programs in in in the tech
industry like they've invested more in
it than and i than i believe any other
social media platform and
the some of the biggest heroes inside
the company are the researchers because
they are boldly asking real questions
and being willing to say awkward truths
um the fact that facebook is throwing
them under the bus i think is
unacceptable and i just want researchers
to know that i stand with them and that
i see them or maybe we should say as the
name of one book the ugly truth
what about facebook blocking researchers
at nyu from accessing the platform does
that concern you these are outside
researchers um i am deeply concerned so
for context for those who are not
familiar with this research there are
researchers at nyu who because facebook
does not publish
enough data on political advertisements
or how they are distributed these are
advertisements that influence our
democracy and how it operates
they created a plug-in that allowed
people to opt in to volunteer to help
collect this data collectively and
facebook lashed out at them and even
banned some of their individual accounts
the fact that facebook is so scared of
even basic transparency that it it goes
out of its way to block researchers who
are asking awkward questions shows you
the need for congressional oversight and
why we need to do federal research and
federal regulations on this very good
thank you thank you for your work
thanks senator klobuchar uh senator
markey
thank you um
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
incredible leadership on this issue
um
as early as 2012
facebook has wanted to allow children
under the age of 12
to use this platform
at that time in 2012 i wrote a letter to
facebook
asking questions about what data
it planned to collect and whether the
company intended to serve targeted ads
at children
now here we are nine years later
debating the very same issues
today
ms hogan
you've made it abundantly clear
why facebook wants to bring more
children onto the platform
it's to hook them early just like
cigarettes so that they become lifelong
users so facebook's profits increase
yet we should also ask why in the last
nine years
has the company not launched facebook
for kids or instagram for kids after all
from the testimony here today facebook
appears to act without regard to any
moral code for any conscience or instead
puts profit about people profit above
all else the reason why facebook hasn't
officially permitted kids 12 and under
to use its platform is because the child
online privacy protection act
of 1998 that i'm the author of exists
because there is a privacy law on the
books which i authored that gives the
federal trade commission regulatory
power to stop websites and social media
companies from invading the privacy of
our children 12 and under
that's why we need to expand the child
online privacy protection act that's why
we need to pass
the kids act that senator blumenthal and
i have introduced and why we need an
algorithmic justice act to pass because
the absence of regulation
leads to harming teens stoking division
damaging our democracy
um that's what you've told us today so
miss hogan i want you to come back to
the protections
that you are calling on us
to enact this isn't complicated
we're going to be told online all day
with these paid
um
facebook people oh congress can't act
they're not experts it's too complicated
for
congress just get out of the way you're
not experts well
this isn't complicated facebook and its
big tech lobbyists are blocking
my bills to protect kids because it
would cost them money that's how
complicated it is so let's start with
the kids act and senator blumenthal and
i that would ban influencer marketing to
kids today's popular influencers pedal
products while they flaunt their lavish
lifestyles to young users can you
explain
how allowing influencer marketing to
teens and children makes facebook more
money
the business model that provides mostly
a great deal of the content on instagram
is one where um people produce content
for free
they put on instagram free no one's
charged for it but many of those content
creators have sponsorships from
from brands or from other
affiliate programs
facebook needs those content creators to
continue to make content so that we will
view content and in the process few more
ads
facebook
provides tools to support influencers
and who do influencer marketing because
it gives them the supply of content that
allows them to keep people on the
platform viewing more ads making more
money for them
yeah so
i am actually the author of the 1990
children's television act
what does that do well it says to all
the television networks in america stop
preying upon children stop using all of
your power in order to try to get young
children in our country hooked on the
products that are going to be sold we
had to pass a law
to ban television stations from doing
this
that's why i knew that after my law
passed in 1996 to break up the
monopolies
of the telecommunications industry and
allow in
the googles and the
facebooks and all the other companies
you name it that we would need a child
privacy protection there because
everyone would just move over to that
new venue
it was pretty obvious and of course the
industry said no way we're going to have
privacy laws for adults and they blocked
me from putting that on the books in
1996
but at least for children i got up to
age 12 that's all i could get
out of
the industry but
we also
know that
as time has moved on it they become even
more sophisticated uh so that
the kids act is necessary to stop
children and teen apps from being
features such as likes and follower
accounts that quantify popularity ms
hogan can you explain how allowing these
features that create an online
popularity contest makes facebook more
money
just to make sure so i i am only
familiar with issues regarding teens
from the research i have read at
facebook's
so i want to put that caviar in there um
the research i have seen with regard to
quantifiable popularity is that as long
as comments are allowed so this is not a
quantitative thing this is just comments
as long as long as comments are still on
posts on instagram take just taking
likes off instagram
doesn't fix the social comparison
problem that you know teenage girls are
smart they see that sally is prettier
than them her pictures are really good
she gets tons of comments they don't get
very many comments right um and so
i do think we need larger interventions
than just removing quantitative measures
facebook has a product that is very
attractive
the reason why they have the study of
problematic use is because it is kind of
addictive
and those kinds of things like having
lots of little feedback loops keeps kids
engaged and like i mentioned earlier
part of why facebook switched over to
meaningful social interactions was it
found that if you got more likes more
comments more research you produced more
content
and so having those systems of little
rewards makes people produce more
content which means we view more content
and we view more ads which makes them
more money okay and
the kids act that senator blumenthal and
i are advocating for also um prohibits
amplification of dangerous and violent
content to children and teens can you
explain how algorithms pushing that
dangerous content makes facebook more
money
and i don't think facebook ever set out
to intentionally promote
divisive extreme polarizing content
i do think though that that they are
aware of the side effects of the choices
they have made around amplification and
they know that algorithmic based ranking
so engagement based ranking keeps you on
their sites longer
you have long you have longer sessions
you show up more often and that makes
them more money
so do you believe we have to ban all
features that quantify popularity as a
starting point in legislation
um
as i as i covered before the internal
research i've seen is that removing
things like likes alone if you don't
remove things like comments
it doesn't have a huge impact on social
comparison so i do believe we need to
have a more integrated um solution for
these issues do should we ban targeted
advertisements to children i strongly
encourage banning targeted
advertisements to children
and we need to have oversight in terms
of i think the algorithms will likely
still learn the interests of kids and
match ads to those kids even if the
advertiser can't articulate and want to
target on this interest right how much
money does facebook made make from
targeting children
i don't know what fraction of their
revenue comes from children okay so
ultimately children are not commodities
no they've always been given
historically special protections that's
what the children's television act of
1990 is all about
they've always been given this special
safety zone so the children can grow up
without being preyed upon
by marketers
and i was a boy
and the salesman would knock on the
front door my mother would just say tell
him i'm not home
that man is not getting into our living
room
well i would say to my
mother but you are home not to him she
would say
well
we need to give parents the ability just
to say
no one's home for you
and your company and your attempts to
prey upon children to get into our
living room
that's our moment in history we have to
make sure that we respond to the
challenge thank you mr chairman
thank you uh senator markey and my
thanks to senator markey for his
leadership over many years
on protecting children uh as you've
heard he was a
champion in the house of representatives
before coming here well before i was in
the united states senate but around the
time i was elected attorney general i've
been very pleased and
honored to work with him on
uh legislation now going forward and i
join him in thanking you i have just a
few concluding questions and
i seem to be the last one left standing
here so the good news is i don't think
we'll have others but
as you may know
um
you do know my office created
an instagram user identified as a 13
year old
girl
she followed a few
easily identifiable
accounts on
weight loss dieting eating disorders and
she was deluged literally within a day
of
content
pushed to her by
algorithms
that
in effect promoted
self-injury and eating disorders are you
surprised by that fact
i'm not surprised by that fact facebook
has internal research where they have
done even
more gentle versions of that experiment
where they have started from things like
interest in healthy recipes so not even
extreme dieting and because of the
nature of engagement-based ranking and
amplification of interests
that ver that that imaginary user was
pushed or that that real account was
pushed towards extreme dieting and
pro-anorexia content very rapidly
and that's the algorithm that's the
algorithm
that algorithm could be changed the
algorithm definitely could be changed i
i have first-hand experience from having
worked at pinterest pinterest used to be
an application that was heavily based
just on you follow certain people's pins
and those are put into your feed
and over time it grew to be much much
more heavily based on recommendations
that the algorithm would figure out what
are you interested in
you can have wonderful experiences that
are based on human interactions so these
are human scale technologies not
computers choosing what we focus on
so the average parent listening here
worried about
their daughter or son
being deluged with these kinds of
content
would want that kind of algorithm
changed i would think and would welcome
the oversight that you're recommending
i i believe parents deserve more options
and more choices and today they don't
know even what they could be asking for
i just received by text literally
about
15 minutes ago
a message from someone in connecticut
and i'm going to read it to you
it's from a dad
i'm in tears right now watching your
interaction
with francis halgen
my 15 year old daughter loved her body
at 14
was on instagram constantly
and maybe posting too much suddenly she
started hating her body
her body dysmorphia now anorexia
and was in deep deep trouble before we
found treatment
i fear she'll never be the same
i'm brokenhearted
i think people tend to lose sight of the
real world impact yeah
and um
i think that's the reason that you're
here
i'd just like to invite you
if you have any words to those
other
employees at big tech the workers who
may be troubled by the misconduct or
unethical conduct
that they see what you would tell them
we live in
a pattern that we have seen throughout
time with regard to technologies is that
humans are very crafty people like we
find interesting solutions
we often get out over our skis
right we we develop things that are of a
larger scale than we know really know
how to handle
and what we have done in the past is
when we see this happen we take a step
back and we find institutions and we
find frameworks for doing these things
in a safe way
we live in a moment where whistleblowers
are very important because these
technological systems are walled off
they are very complicated they're things
that you need to be a specialist to
really understand the consequences of
and the fact that we've been having the
exact same kinds of false choice
discussions about what to do about
facebook you know is it about privacy or
oversight is it about censorship or
safety like the fact that we're being
asked these false choices is just an
illustration of what happens when the
real solutions are hidden inside of
companies
we need more
tech employees to come forward through
legitimate channels like the sec or
congress
to make sure that the public has the
information they need in order to have
technologies be human-centric
not not not computer-centric
thank you
on that note we'll conclude
thank you for an extraordinary
testimony
uh i think that uh anybody watching
would be impressed and much better
informed and you've done
america real public service i think
thank you
uh the record will remain open for a
week i'm sorry for two weeks any
senators who want to
submit questions for the records should
do so by october for uh october 19th
this hearing is adjourned thank you
you